nous allons pouvoir commencer nos
travaux j'espère dans la plus grande
sérénité et donc nous recevons
aujourd'hui madame madame Amélie oua
casttera ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse des sports et
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
madame la ministre vous avez déjà été
auditionné à plusieurs reprise par notre
commission mais uniquement sur les
sujets relatifs au sports et aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et nous
entendrons aujourd'hui sur votre feuille
de route et dans le cadre d'une audition
que le bureau a souhaité prioritairement
dédié à l'éducation nationale dont vous
avez désormais aussi la charge les
chantiers qui vous attendent sont
nombreux et nous intéressent au premier
chef lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire renforcement de l'attractivité
de la de la profession d'enseignant choc
des savoirs inclusion des élèves en
situation de handicap amélioration des
performances scolaires et plusieurs
membres de notre commission travaillent
d'ailleurs en ce moment sur certains de
ces sujets des annonces ont été faites
lors de la déclaration de politique
générale qui concerne en particulier la
revalorisation des personnels scolaires
médicaux-sociaux et la prise en charge
par l'État des aesh sur la pause
méridienne pouvez-vous nous présenter
ces mesures et leur calendrier voilà ça
c'était ma question mais de nombreux
collègues en auront beaucoup d'autres
mais en attendant je vais vous céder la
parole pour les propos
liminires je vous remercie beaucoup
madame la Présidente en effet j'avais
pris l'habitude de venir devant vous
pour évoquer les sujets relatifs au
sports aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques je suis ravi de le faire
aujourd'hui avec ce périmètre élargi et
cette responsabilité pour l'éducation
nationale pour l'école pour la réussite
de tous nos élèves de toutes nos écoles
et je
suis sincèrement heureuse d'avoir
l'opportunité de cet échange avec vous
cet après-midi on le sait on l'a vu avec
une acuité particulière ces dernières
semaines les Français attendent beaucoup
de leur école ils ont raison cette
attente est légitime et je veux y
répondre avec le plus possible de clarté
avec eu de l'énergie et avec la capacité
à donner y compris au cœur de mon
administration du sens sur les réformes
que nous conduisons avec cette volonté
partagée d'aider nos élèves le mieux
possible et d'exprimer au personnel de
l'éducation nationale la confiance qui
est la mienne dans leur expertise dans
leur expérience dans leur volonté au
plus près du terrain de trouver les
solutions pour la réussite de nos élèves
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous êtes les relais de ces attentes à
travers les travaux que vous menez au
sein de cette commission pour contrôler
pour éclairer l'action du gouvernement
et je sais votre attachement à notre
modèle d'école à l'ensemble de nos
écoles et tout particulièrement à
l'école publique je je voudrais avant de
partager les axes de ma feuille de route
évoquer avec vous le sousbassement de
cette ambition que nous portons avec le
président de la République avec le
Premier ministre pour l'école qui est
celle d'un budget renforcé dans le cadre
de la loi de finances pour 2024 où vous
avez pu voter des crédits inédits pour
notre éducation nationale un budget 2024
qui s'élève à
63,8 milliards d'euros hausse de près de
8 % et un montant qui représente 15
milliards de plus qu'en 2017 cette
augmentation est très significative plus
30 % depuis le début du premier
quinquena alors même que la démographie
de nos élèves est en baisse c'est donc
un effort tout à fait particulier cet
investissement historique il est
lui-même à la hauteur de l'enjeu
historique qui est le nôtre faire
réussir tous les élèves toutes les
écoles ma feuille de route ma feuille de
route j'ai choisi de la structuré autour
de trois axes qui sont très inspirés
vous le verrez des impulsions données
par le Premier ministre dans l'exercice
de ses précédentes fonctions la première
de
ces premier de ces axes c'est de
parvenir et je reprends volontiers à mon
compte sa formule mettre de l'exigence à
tous les étages remettre de l'exigence à
tous les étages ça suppose d'abord de
réaffirmer l'autorité des professeurs
sur la vie de classe sur leur
enseignement sur les décisions de
notation avec la fin des correctifs
académiques dès l'exercice
2024 pour les épreuves du bac et du
brevet dès la rentrée 2024 pour le bac
et le
brevetor aussi de nos professeurs sur
les décisions de redoublement en donnant
le dernier mot à l'équipe
pédagogique le pendant de cette autorité
réaffirmé pour nos professeurs c'est le
choc des savoirs un choc des savoirs qui
se déclinent à tous les niveaux au
primaire au collège au lycée dans la
continuité là aussi des efforts engagés
depuis 2017 tout particulièrement sur le
primaire où nous avons déjà en terme de
résultat pour nos élèves des
satisfactions
importantes vous avez en tête le
dédoublement de nos classes CP CE1 en
Rep et en Rep plus que nous parachevons
avec un dédoublement pour les classes de
grandes section de maternelle mais nous
allons au-delà pour le primaire avec la
révision des programmes de français et
de mathématiques l'introduction d'un
certain nombre d'inspir de la méthode de
Singapour en mathématique et le travail
mené autour de la labellisation des
manuels scolaires en mat et en français
au CP et au CE1 avec pour la première
fois un effort renforcé de l'État au
financement de ces manuels à hauteur de
30 millions d'euros en loi de finance
pour
2024 au niveau du
collège la dimension probablement la
plus emblématique du choc des savoirs et
la mise en place sur laquelle nous
reviendront sûrement des groupes de
niveaux dès la rentrée prochaine pour
les classes de 6e et de
5e une évolution rendue nécessaire par
la dégradation des résultats et qui sont
retracés notamment par l'enquête PISA
tant en français qu'en mathématique qui
doit nous conduire à mettre en place des
méthodes pédagogiques innovantes des
contexte
d'apprentissage différents pour nos
enfants et des
nos
professeurs à mieux gérer
l'hétérogénéité des classes aujourd'hui
ils nous disent combien ils ont des
difficulté à faire le grand écart dans
un système qui produit à la fois plus
d'élèves en difficulté et moins d'élèves
excellents
aujourd'hui face à ces différents
écueils nous voulons avec les groupes de
niveau remettre en marche l'ascenseur
scolaire surtout pas mettre fin au
collège unique puisque la totalité des
élèves continueront de faire la totalité
du programme nous ne voulons pas créer
non plus des classes de niveau nous
avons des groupes dédiés pour les maths
et le français et nous ne voulons
surtout pas nous inscrire dans une
logique de relégation scolaire bien au
contraire c'est dans une logique de
progrès que nous voulons nous inscrire
en permettant à chaque conseil de classe
l'évaluation des progrès effectué par
les élèves pour pouvoir les réallouer en
tant que de besoin à travers ces
différents groupes et nous dotons les
établissements de moyens supplémentaires
pour la mise en place de ces groupes de
niveau à hauteur de 2330 ETP nous
pourrons revenir ensemble sur ces
déclinaisons un autre élément
emblématique du choc des savoirs au
niveau du collège c'est la mise en place
à titre exp
mental dans un premier temps à la
rentrée 24 et de manière généralisée à
la rentrée 25 de ce que Gabriel Atal a
appelé la prépalcée qui doit permettre
aux élèves qui échouent au brevet
d'avoir un parcours avant de réattaquer
une seconde dans des conditions
renforcées de niveau et de confiance en
eux un autre élément emblématique est au
niveau du collège la refonte du brevet
avec une un poids renforcé donné aux
épreuves terminales par rapport au
contrôle continu cette dynamique du choc
des savoirs elle s'exprime aussi au
niveau du lycée avec par exemple la
nouvelle épreuve avancé du bac en
mathématique en juin de
2026 avec la révision du programme de
mathématique en cohérence avec cette
évolution tant en seconde qu'en première
et la mise en place aussi de d'exercice
tant en mathématique qu'en français à
travers l'utilisation d'innovation
numérique pour les aider dans cette voie
et puis c'est aussi la réforme de la
voie professionnelle sur laquelle je
sais que vous pouvez avoir certaines
interrogations et qui vise à la fois à
pousser l'excellence avec par exemple le
renforcement du volume horaire des
enseignements la création de mention
pour les lauréats du Cap la création là
aussi de groupes de besoins réduits en
math et en français et la mise en place
de voix d'étude ou de voix insérant sous
la forme d'un y pour le cycle
terminal je voudrais aussi mentionner
que cette volonté d'avancer sur le choc
des savoirs s'accompagne d'une attention
plus élevée que jamais en faveur de
l'accompagnement des enfants notamment
ceux en difficulté c'est le sens donné
au dispositif devoir fait obligatoire en
6e mais que nous faisons monter en
puissance comme nous faisons monter en
puissance les stages de réussite et
comme dans le cadre de la généralisation
de l'accueil 818 en éducation
prioritaire nous allons accompagner les
enfants en complément du temps scolaire
c'est aussi la mise en place des
parcours renforcé en 6e et en 5e sur le
temps scolaire pour les élèves qui sont
en grande difficulté à travers des
contrats d'objectif
individualisé 2uxème axe de cette
feuille de route c'est l'attractivité
des métiers de l'enseignement et le
renforcement de notre efficacité en
matière
d'organisation cette volonté de mieux
porter l'attractivité des métiers elle
vaut évidemment d'abord pour le métier
d'enseignant et nous engageons une
réinvention de la formation initiale
autour d'un concours qui sera à l'avenir
placé non plus à bac + 5 mais à bac + 3
avec une révision de l'architecture sur
des licences en cohérence et de nouveaux
contenus de formation qu'avec ma
collègue Sylvie retaillot nous allons
proposer au Premier ministre et au
président de la République cette
attention à nos enseignants je veux
aussi que nous l'apportions à la
formation continu qui doit être repensé
ainsi qu'au déroulé de carrière et
notamment aux aménagements rendus
nécessaires pour les milieu de carrière
où nous savons qu'augmente le mal-être
et les départs volontaires de nos
enseignants
je voudrais aussi souligner l'attention
qui est la nôtre aux autres métiers qui
concourent au service public de
l'enseignement tout particulièrement à
nos aesh qui font un travail
considérable pour accompagner les élèves
en situation de de handicap et pour
lesquels vous savez notre mobilisation
depuis plusieurs années à travers des
création de postees à travers des
revalorisations salariales et à travers
des aménagements qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui par exemple de leur proposer
des contrats à durée indéterminé au bout
de 3 ans et non plus au lieu de 6 comme
auparavant et madame la Présidente vous
l'avez mentionné l'engagement qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui avec le Premier
ministre de prendre en charge le temps
des aesâ sur la pause méridienne pour
que l'État puisse assumer l'ensemble de
ses responsabilités vous savez aussi
l'attention qui est la nôtre à la
revalorisation concernant les infirmiers
et infirmières scolaires nous en avons
aujourd'hui 7500 le Premier ministre
s'est engagé dans la déclaration de
politique générale à ce que nous
puissions leur verser une prime de 800 €
dès mai 2024 et qu'à comptter de cette
date nous puissions nous engager dans
une revalorisation mensuelle de 200 €
nets par mois tout en autorisant le
cumul de leur exercice avec l'exercice
libéral nous voulons également renforcer
l'action des assistantes et des
assistants sociaux mais aussi mieux
accompagner nos contractuels qui font
bien souvent un travail remarquable au
côté des équipes pédagogiques et
notamment améliorer les conditions de
leur recrutement et de leur
formation s'agissant de notre
organisation vous savez l'attention
prioritaire qui doit être la nôtre à la
question des remplacements remplacement
de courte durée sur lesquels nous avons
déjà un première série de résultats tout
à fait probant avec le triplement du
nombre d'heures remplacé mais également
la nécessité qui est la nôtre de
travailler aussi sur le sujet des
remplacements de longue durée et
d'embarquer toute la communauté
éducative y compris dans le privé autour
de cette problématique essentielle pour
nos élèves des remplacements et de la
qualité de ces remplacements sur toutes
ces dimensions nous voulons avancer
comme nous voulons avancer sur le
troisième axe de ma feuille de route qui
est celui consistant à bâtir
avec vous tous avec la représentation
nationale avec la communauté éducative
une école qui soit une école de
l'épanouissement républicain dans
laquelle ni la peur ni le harcèlement
n'est leur place vous savez là encore le
plan d'action engagé dans le cadre du
programme PHARE depuis plusieurs années
contre le harcèlement à l'école et le
durcissement de cette lutte qui a été
impulsée par mon prédécesseur nous
continuons et nous rendront compte dans
les tous prochains jours de l'évolution
de ces phénomènes de harcèlement ainsi
que du déploiement de nos mesures pour
nous inscrire dans une logique de 100 %
prévention avec notamment des référents
désignés dans les établissements la
montée en puissance des équipes
pédagogiques avec le renfort de 150 ETP
supplémentaires mais aussi le 100 %
détection avec la montée en puissance du
3018 et le 100 % solution qui doit nous
permettre pris dans le primaire de faire
changer d'école l'élève harceleur et non
plus l'élève harcelés une école aussi où
nous allons transmettre mieux encore les
valeurs de la République dans une
logique de protection de garantie de la
laïcité dans tous les établissements de
notre pays mais aussi dans une logique
d'engagement avec la montée en puissance
du SNU dont le président de la
République aujourd'hui porte l'ambition
d'une généralisation
nous voulons aussi que notre école de
l'épanouissement
républicain soit une école attentive à
la santé de l'enfant à son bien-être
c'est le sens des développements des
cours d'empathie c'est le développement
aussi de la santé scolaire aussi de
l'ouverture aux besoins de l'enfant et à
ses apprentissages à la découverte de
lui-même de sa relation aux autres et à
l'éducation à la vie affective et
relationnelle en même temps que nous
portons une ambition plus forte que
jamais en matière de mixité sociale et
de mixité scolaire à travers l'ensemble
des établissement de notre pays une
école de l'épanouissement républicain
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
aussi une école inclusive nous allons
porter ensemble l'acte 2 de cette école
inclusive pour faire en sorte d'avoir
les bonnes modalités d'accompagnement
humain mais aussi matériel pédagogique
dans une logique de renforcement global
de l'accessibilité pour les enfants en
situation de handicap vous connaissez
les engagements pris par le Président de
la République lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap une école aussi
qui soit plus ouverte vers la société
qui regarde et aborde tous les parcours
avec la même considération y compris
dans la voie professionnelle y compris
avec des initiatives comme la montée en
puissance de la découverte des métiers
lors de la 5e et avec la mise en place
des stages en fin de seconde stage de 15
jours qui doivent aider nos élèves à
mieux anticiper leur découvert des
métiers et leurs besoins d'orientation
enfin c'est une école qui fait toute sa
place à l'ouverture au sport et à la
culture en en renforçant la dimension au
cœur des enseignements mais aussi en les
développant tant de le périscolaire
qu'en extrascolaire j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'accueil 818 en zone
d'éducation prior prioritaire mais je
veux aussi mentionner la montée en
puissance de nos classes à horair
aménagés tant dans le champ sportif que
dans celui des Cham et des chasses qui
doivent nous permettre de faire en sorte
que l'école au sens le plus large et le
plus complet du terme sache reconnaître
les singularités de nos enfants faire
grandir leurs talents et les doter plus
que jamais à un moment où la prégance
des écrans virire souvent à l'addiction
leur redonner des centres d'intérêt qui
feront le sel de leur vie toute cette
feuille de route mesdames et messieurs
les députés s'inscrit dans une logique
où ce ministère porte aussi une ambition
extraordinairement forte pour la
préparation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui doivent éclairer notre
jeunesse qui doivent les inspirer leur
donner l'exemple avec de nombreuses
initiatives qui permettront à nos
publics scolaires de se rendre
participer à ces épreuves ompique et
paralympique et plus largement qui
auront pour effet de mettre en valeur
comme jamais notre pays je vous remercie
pour votre attention et me tiens à votre
écoute et à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci merci
Madame la Ministre donc maintenant nous
allons passer aux orateurs de groupe
pour 2 minutes et je vous indique mes
collègues qu'après les orateurs de
groupe nous avons 40 députés qui sont
inscrits donc je prendrai deux salbes de
questions 20 et 20 donc par ordre
d'arrivver mais dans le respect de la
composition de notre assemblée donc
voilà je je vous le dit ne soyez pas
impatient donc nous allons commencer par
le groupe renaissance pour 2 minutes
avec Stéphane
Mazar madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues madame la ministre nous vous
accueillons au sein de notre commission
en tant que nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports et des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques 2024 il s'agit pour vous
d'un très grand ministère qui a suscité
beaucoup de commentaires et si votre
bilan est particulièrement élogieux dans
le domaine du sport en cette année
olympique se profile désormais devant
vous un autre grand défi qui est celui
pour paraphraser le Premier ministre de
mener la mer des bataille à savoir
l'éducation de notre
jeunesse et c'est bien Madame la
Ministre sur le bilan de cette action
que vous devrez être jugé madame la
ministre vous qui êtes rompu à la devise
olympique êtes-vous disposé à l'appquer
nationale en allant plus vite parce
qu'il y a urgence à redonner à l'école
sa place centrale une trajectoire a déjà
été amorcé par votre prédécesseur
autorité du professeur respect de
l'institution renforcement des savoirs
fondamentaux pouvez-vous madame la
ministre nous confirmer que ces
objectifs sont partagés par tous les
acteurs et d'ors et déjà mis en œuvre en
allant plus haut parce que nous étions
parfois tombés très bas en continuant à
faire progresser le budget de votre
ministère cette augmentation c'est
notamment traduite par une hausse sans
précédent de la rémunération des
enseignants des aesh et plus
généralement de tous les acteurs de
l'éducation madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous faire un bilan d'étapes
sur les augmentations des professeurs
liés au Pact dont on sait qu'elles n'ont
pas toujours été accueillies très
favorablement sur le terrain en allant
plus fort parce qu'on a souvent fait
preuve de faiblesse en réaffirmant au
travers l'école les valeurs de notre
République et notamment celle de la
laïcité comment madame la ministre
comptez-vous faire pour que l'école
reste cette forteresse imprenable et que
nos enfants apprennent à devenir de
futurs citoyens éclairés et engagés
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur le
déploimement envisagé des cours de
théâtre sur l'expérimentation de la
tenue unique ou encore sur la lecture
des grands textes enfin et parce que
dans la nouvelle devise olympique il y a
aussi le mot ensemble comment
comptez-vous madame la ministre
appréhender les territoires les plus
fragiles de notre République et je pense
notamment nos territoires ruraux dont la
déprise démographique fait toujours
courir le risque de suppression de
postees ou de fermeture d'écooles merci
monsieur le député pour le rassemblement
national Julie lechanteux pour 2 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre je me permet de vous
interpeller au nom du groupe
rassemblement national car comme bon
nombre de français nous sommes inquiets
inquiet du niveau catastrophique de
l'éducation nationale inquiet pour
l'avenir de nos enfants le classement
PISA a publié en décembre sa dernière
enquête le bilan est affligeant la
France 7e puissance mondiale se classe
péniblement 23e les résultats sont en
net recul les mathématiques et la
compréhension écrite sont
particulièrement à la peine vous avez
dit vouloir vous saisir du problème et
avait en ce sens annoncé quelques
mesurettes sur les mathématiques bien
que leur étroitesse face à la tâche ne
puisse que nous étonné elles auraient pu
être salué comme une petite avancée
elles auraient pu si en même temps le
Premier ministre n'annonçait pas
triomphal un nouveau programme
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle laisser nos enfants tranquilles
et apprenez leur plutôt à lire à écrire
et à conter nous ne pouvons qu'être
affligé par l'effondrement du niveau
dans toutes les disciplines l'histoire
par exemple où seul 50 % des 1624 ans
savent que la Révolution française a eu
lieu en
1789 face à cela Madame le Ministre les
petites mesures et les odieuses normes
sociétal que vous souhaitez implanter ne
sont pas à la hauteur c'est une preuve
de mépris envers les élèves et les
générations futures que de permettre la
continuité d'un système aussi inefficace
votre prédécesseur éclair disait vouloir
réformer et avait énuméré quelques
mesures nécessaires qui étaient toutes
puisées dans le programme du
rassemblement national ce fut une
surprise pour ceux qui enfermés dans de
vulgaires querelles politiciennes
préféraent le symbole plutôt que de
s'atteler à l'éducation et à l'avenir
des enfants nous attendons de vous
Madame le Ministre des garanties
aurez-vous le courage de lutter contre
l'idéologie d'une gauche extrémiste aux
abois qui gangrainent l'enseignement
aurez-vous la volonté politique de
mettre en place les mesures nécessair
concrètes afin de lutter contre les
résultats médiocres que les classements
internationaux clament à la face du
monde seulement en math mais aussi dans
les autres merci madame la députée j'ai
accepté un petit dépassement pour le
groupe Renaissance j'ai accepté le même
pour le groupe rassemblement national
donc j'ai coupé le micro et ce sera de
même pour les autes donc on a de
nombreux orateurs si vous ne respectez
pas le temps de parole ça va être
vraiment très très compliqué donc
maintenant pour LFI Léo Valter à la
parole et seul Léo Valter a la parole
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre je voudrais aujourd'hui vous
parler d'une femme engagée injustement
attaquée sur ses valeurs et sur son sens
du service public une femme pour qui
l'argent n'a jamais été un moteur pour
qui le sujet c'est la passion c'est
l'investissement une femme qui chaque
jour et dans l'action au service de
l'éducation nationale pour faire réussir
tous les élèves elle est heureuse quand
les enfants sont bien formés avec de
l'exigence dans la maîtrise des savoirs
fondamentaux qu'ils sont épanouis qu'ils
ont des amis qu'ils sont bien qu'ils se
sentent en sécurité en confiance quand
elle rapporte sa rémunération actuelle
au volume d'heur que chaque semaine elle
s'enfourne en bossant souvent le weekend
et même pendant les deux petits mois
d'été elle trouve qu'elle n'est pas bien
payée mais elle sait qu'elle a une
mission fondamentale elle est passionnée
mais par ce qu'elle fait tout entière à
ses responsabilités cette femme c'est
une institutrice une accompagnante
d'élèves en situation de handicap une
assistante d'éducation une professeur
une conseillère principale d'éducation
oui mais voilà elle qui croit en l'école
de la République en l'école publique
aujourd'hui la réalité lui donne tort
elle a beau avoir l'amour du travail
bien fait le goût de l'effort
contrairement à beaucoup d'étiquettes
que beaucoup de gens veulent lui coller
sur les épaules elle a beau avoir bien
du mérite aujourd'hui elle est fatiguée
blessée par le discrédit que vos propos
ont jeté sur l'école publique ulcéré
parce que les épisodes de ces derniers
jours révèle du séparatisme scolaire et
des privilèges de quelques-uns inquiète
de la dégradation supplémentaire du
service public d'éducation que prépare
le choc des savoirs de Gabrielle Atal
elle a fait grève jeudi dernier et à
nouveau aujourd'hui après 10 20 25 ou 30
ans de ce métier qu'elle adore mais
qu'elle ne reconnaît plus aujourd'hui
elle elle songe à démissionner
aujourd'hui elle nous écoute madame la
ministre qu'avez-vous à lui dire merci
monsieur le député pour les républicains
anné
jeunevard merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre c'est une audition
bien particulière que nous faisons
aujourd'hui tant la situation est
totalement inhabituel et pour dire le
vrai àees critiques le périmètre
déraisonnablement élargi de votre
ministère les polémiques qui ont
accompagné vos premier pas dans un
ministère qui vous est inconnu et dans
une fonction politique récente pour vous
la succession d'un ministre devenu le
premier qui vous a laissé une feuille de
route qui ne porte pas votre marque la
grève récente et celle qui s'annonce les
bruits qui courent sur votre possible
départ du ministère tout cela rend
extrêmement difficile pour ne pas dire
impossible votre tâche dans un ministère
réputé difficile et pourtant jamais
l'école n'a eu autant besoin d'une
action forte d'une ligne claire et
surtout de la restauration de la
confiance de la nation confiance qui
s'érode un peu plus à chaque évaluation
internationale sur le niveau de nos
élèves en français et en mathématique
discipline fondamentale évaluation qui
nous relègue à des niveaux humiliants
par rapport au pays de l'OCDE la mise en
place espérée mais déjà contestée du
choc des savoirs suppose de la
détermination et du savoir-faire le
contexte est rendu encore plus difficile
par les suppressions de classes très
nombreuses en milieux rural qui soulève
un peu partout dans notre pays la colère
des parents des enseignants et des élus
locaux mes cè évoquont sans doute ce
sujet nous avons entendu votre feuille
de route madame la ministre mais comme
vous le savez tout est dans la capacité
de l'exécution alors madame la ministre
comment comptez-vous rétablir le
dialogue avec les enseignants comment
comptez-vous empêcher que ne renaisse
une opposition entre le public et le
privé que vos déclarations ont
malheureusement contribué à relancer
sans doute malgré vous alors je vous
pose directement la question madame la
ministre pensez-vous être à même de P
votre
ministérielle merci madame la députée
pour les démocrates Laurent
Croisier madame la présidente madame la
ministre ch collègu le groupe démocrate
considère qu'il y a urgence à élever le
niveau de l'école à redonner de
l'attractivité au métiers de professeur
et à restaurer leur autorité dans la
société tout d'abord nous croyons
fermement qu'il faut repenser notre
système éducatif pour Noé avec l'égalité
des chances et élever le niveau de tous
les élèves dans cette optique nous
défendons l'idée d'un collège qui
s'adapte aux besoins de chacun des
élèves il n'est pas question de revenir
sur le collège unique mais sur le
collège uniforme dont les difficultés
sont connues pour proposer des parcours
individualisés selon nos retours la mise
en place des groupes de niveau semble
présenter des difficultés d'organisation
principaux de collèg clair de façon très
concrète comment comptez-vous anticiper
et régler ces difficultés ensuite il n'y
a évidemment pas d'école sans
professeurs la profession a besoin de
reconnaissance et de soutien nous sommes
convaincu que redonner de l'attractivité
au métiers de professeur passe d'une
part par la poursuite de la
revalorisation salariale et par
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
des enseignants étroitement lié aux
conditions d'apprentissage des élèves
nous avons proposé d'une part une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle de
revalorisation salariale et d'autre part
de profiter de la baisse démographique
scolaire pour abaisser les effectifs des
classes quelles sont vos intentions sur
ces sujets enfin nous souhaitons des
enseignants mieux formés experts dans
leur domaine et mieux préparé à la
pédagogie et aux réalités du terrain
nous privilégions le retour d'un
concours à 3 suivi d'une période de
fonctionnaire stagiaire de 2 ans et
ainsi maintenir la validation du diplôme
à bac + 5 cette évolution verra-t-elle
le jour à la rentrée 2024 le groupe
démocrate est très exigeant sur la
concrétisation des annonces faites par
le gouvernement mais déterminé à vous
accompagner nous le devons à notre école
à nos élèvesci monsieur le député pour
le groupe socialiste Boris
Vallot merci madame la Présidente il a
évidemment des choix personnels des
choix familiaux qui lorsque l'on prend
des responsabilités posent des questions
politiques et dessinent aussi un certain
rapport à la question scolaire et et à
l'école madame la ministre la première
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est celle de votre rapport à l'école
publique et en particulier à la question
de la mixité sociale du séparatisme
scolaire du fait qu'un certain nombre
d'établissement cumulent toutes les
difficultés quand d'autres n'en
accueillent aucune comment construire
une nation d'ég quand on ne grandit pas
en emble en particulier lorsque l'on
prétend à la cohésion nationale et au
rarmement civique je veux savoir quelle
est votre politique ou quelle sera votre
politique en la matière nous en avons eu
aucune depuis 7 ans et quelle part vous
entendez que le privé y occupe de la
même manière madame la ministre j'ai
entendu que vous plidiez pour une école
de l'épanouissement républicain je
voudrais savoir quel est votre rapport
aux valeurs de la République quelle est
la conception que vous avez de la
pédagogie de la laïcité et de la
pédagogie des valeurs de la République
et de de quelle manière vous entendez
veiller dans le public comme dans le
privé à ce que ces valeurs soient
scrupuleusement enseignées je voudrais
de la même manière vous interrogez sur
votre conception de l'égalité des sexes
de l'éducation à la sexualité de la
l'éducation à l'égalité de de genre il y
a un rapport du Conseil supérieur des
programmes sur cette question qui n'a
pas été rendu publique il est depuis
décembre sur le bureau de votre
prédécesseur et désormais du vôtre
entendez-vous le rendre le rendre public
et là aussi dans l'hypothèse où ne
serait pas remplis correctement les
devoirs des établissements dans
l'application des programmes quelle
sanction entendez-vous entendez-vous
prendre vous avez par ailleurs évoqué
les moyens de l'éducation nationale et
j'évoque la question des groupes de
niveau quelle différence faites-vous
entre groupe de niveau et groupe de
besoin et s'agissant des groupe de
niveau quels sont les moyens que vous
entendez consacrés pour les mettre en
place il y a eu 6500 suppressions de
postes depuis le début
depuis 2017 et puis par ailleurs défalqu
de l'inflation le budget de l'Éducation
nationale depuis 2017 entre 2017 et 2022
a baissé de 1,8
%ug vous
avez j'ai accepté 12 secondes de plus
pour tout le monde vous en êtes à
15 pour horizon et apparenté agè
Carel merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre vous succédez à un ministre
qui avait emporté l'aval de nombre
enseignant grâce à des directives
claires et sans encombre les attentes
aujourd'hui sont grandes et justifiées
dans un climat sensible relié entre
autres à la perte de niveau des élèves
une priorité a été donnée à la
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants et du personnel à laquelle
s'est ajouté la mise en place du PACT
enseignant ce Pact est un outil
permettant aux enseignants investis de
faire plus et souvent comme c'est le cas
par exemple pour les voyages de
découverte d'être payé pour leur
investissement supplémentairire ce qui
n'était pas le le cas jusqu'à présent je
pense que ces pactes peuvent être de
véritabl levier pour d'autres missions
non ou mal rémunérées pour autant il ne
reporte pas suffisamment de l'adhésion
comment y remédier Gabriel Atal a
complété ses mesures en tant que Premier
ministre mardi dernier en annonçant en
annonçant pardon d'autres réformes comme
la refondte de la formation des
enseignants par la création des écoles
normales du 21e siècle mais aussi en
proposant que les indemnités des aesh
sur le temps de M du midi soit prise en
charge par l'État afin de permettre une
continuité dans l'accompagnement des
élèves nous pouvez nous pouvons
également aller plus loin en
reconnaissant davantage le travail de
ses accompagnants indispensable pour ces
milliers d'élèves votre prédécesseur
avait également fait du harcèlement une
priorité vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure en prenant enfin de multiples
mesures où en sommes-nous réellement
quelques mois après enfin à propos des
groupes de niveau qui semble être l'un
des principaux motifs de la grève
aujourd'hui il il me semble que cette
notion ne soit pas prise comme une
chance d'égalité ni comme une autre
façon d'enseigner c'est pourtant une
opportunité de faire autrement face à
des élèves en difficulté de permettre de
différencier de donner une chance à
chacun mais dans cette mais cette mesure
semble avoir besoin de clarification
quelle mesure allez-vous prendre pour
emporter l'adhésion des enseignants le
groupe horizon apparenté reste mobilisé
très attentif sur les questions
éducation formation de nos enfants et
des enseignants merci merci Madame
député pour le groupe écologiste
Francesca pascini merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre une classe
dans une école publique est composée de
garçons et de filles qui se mélangent se
confrontent se bagarent ou s'aime au gré
des heures et des jours certains portent
des baskets neuves au troués certains
partent en vacances d'autres n'ont pas
cette chance et n'ont jamais vu la mer
certains ont un excellent niveau
d'autres RAM la plupart mangent à leur
faim trois fois par jour d'autres ne
mangent qu'à la cantine face à eux des
enseignants qui s'en fournent des heures
et qui aiment leur métier ils ne le font
pas pour l'argent de toute façon
contrairement à vous il ne négocient pas
leur salaire et jeeton de présence face
à eux des professeurs qui se démènent
chaque jour pour leurs élèves tous leurs
élèves différents mais égaux face à eux
des chefs d'établissement des CPE des
assistants d'éducation couteaux suisse
qui court jongle coordonne console
s'épuis tiennent grâce aux collègues et
aux enfants tous sont fiers de servir
l'éducation nationale à tous ces
personnels engagés qui luttent avec peu
de moyens qui écument les brocantes pour
acheter du matériel pour la classe qui
organise des ventes de gâteaux pour
financer les sorties scolaires chacune
de vos prises de parole et comme un coup
de poignard dans le dos depuis votre
prise de fonction vous leur démontrez
que tout roule pour les enfants de la
caste privilégié pour ceux qui peuvent
payer 3500 € l'année de scolarité en
demi-pension madame la ministre j'aurais
préféré de vous parler des vrais et
nombreux problèmes de l'école des 200000
enfants en situation d'handicap
déscolarisé des plafonds qui tombent des
classes où il fait trop chaud l'été mais
vu vos prises de parole nous en sommes à
devoir vous rappeler ce qui'est l'école
publique oui l'école publique celle que
je défendrai bec et ongles celle que
vous m connaissez méprisz et contourner
il est il est des moments dans une vie
où l'on sort honoré d'avoir su
reconnaître un échec et l'incapacité de
remplir une fonction arrêtons le
massacre chaque jour porte pour vous
sans Lee de souffrance de casserole de
désaveux devant vous il n'y a qu'un mur
ou une porte de sortie
prenezla merci madame la députée pour le
groupe
Martine merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre une crise de vocation
semble frapper cruellement notre pays
c'est à propos de cette désaffection que
je souhaitais vous interroger et ce
parce qu'elle impacte fortement le
recrutement des enseignants chaque année
en effet il apparaît que le nombre de
candidats se présentant au concours
connait une baisse très inquiétante qui
tend à s'aggraver d'année en année pour
C pour certains concours ils sont sont
moins nombreux que les postes à pourvoir
dans des proportions alarmantes que ce
soit pour le concours de recrutement de
professeurs des écoles que pour le
second degré ou pour certains capèes qui
sont en voie de désérance un autre
élément tout aussi préoccupant est
àointer celui des démission qui auraiit
triplé entre 2013 et
2018 plusieurs facteurs matériels et
symboliques peuvent expliquer cette
désinfeection d'abord le faible niveau
de rémunération au regard des diplômes
exigés rappelons que 12 années de gel
quasi complet des salaires affigé le
premier échelon des des certifiés il en
va de même du manque de reconnaissance
des difficultés du métier la dégradation
des conditions de travail les réformes
qui ont imposé une
bureaucratisation croissante des actes
éducatifes sont des éléments qui
conduisent à une perte du sens du métier
enfin c'est également une dimension plus
symbolique fortement ressentie qui est
celle du déficit de
considération pour finir la question de
la formation des enseignants est pointé
du doigt la formation est perçue comme
trop prescriptive et en décalage avec la
réalité des cours en présentiel au
regard des ces constats madame la
ministre mes questions sont les
suivantes quelle politique salariale et
social comptezvous mettre en œuvre pour
résorber le déficit d'enseignant et
rendre ainsi l'envie aux étudiants de
faire ce qu'il était commun d'appeler le
plus beau métier du monde par ailleurs
pensez-vous que la formation initiale de
nos enseignants préparent correctement
les jeunes professeurs à ce métier merci
merci madame la députée madame la
ministre c'est à vous pour cette
première salve de questions et de
réflexion de la part de nos
orateurs merci madame la Présidente
alors je voudrais d'abord revenir sur
les améliorations intervenues sur les
conditions salariales qui sont
aujourd'hui offertes à nos à nos
enseignants beaucoup d'améliorations
sont intervenues depuis avril 2022 elles
étaient absolument nécessaire indispensa
et attendu et elles nous permettent
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de début de carrière à moins de
2100 € nets et un peu plus de 2460 €
nets en zone d'éducation prioritaire
c'est une augmentation de 11 % qui
résulte à la fois des efforts
intrinsèques que nous avons fait à
travers notamment l'augmentation de la
part socle en septembre 2023 mais aussi
à travers les revalorisations
intervenues du point d'indice pour la
fonction publique et de log 3 de 5 point
d'indice majoré en janvier de
2024 je voudrais aussi souligner les
mesures qui ont été les nôtres pour
fluidifier les déroulements de carrière
je pense notamment à l'augmentation des
taux de promotion pour l'accès au 2e
grade qui est passé de 18 % en 2022 à 22
2 % en 2024 et je pense aussi à la
suppression de l'accès fonctionnel à la
classe exceptionnelle 3e grade à partir
de 2024 qui est un engagement que nous
avons pris et qui doit permettre
d'améliorer l'attractivité des débuts de
carrière nous aurons aussi besoin
puisque la question m'a été posée de
retravailler des initiatives en matière
de milieu de carrière on sait là aussi
que c'est un élément qui est
particulièrement
important qu'il y a dans ces moments-là
une baisse de la motivation une baisse
du bien-être au travail qui doit nous
imposer de prendre l'initiative un
constat aujourd'hui près de 40 % de nos
enseignants sont prêts à changer de
métier et un tiers d'entre eux ne
trouvent plus de sens à leur mission
c'est cet accompagnement que je veux que
nous puissions leur apporter à travers
davantage d'écoute et de prise en compte
de leurs enjeux de bien être des
difficultés auxquelles ils sont
confrontés de la question des tailles
des classes en passant par les
problématiques du logement celle
également relative à l'action sociale ou
à la gestion des applicatifs
informatiques qui créent des conditions
de travail souvent beaucoup trop
complexes pour nos enseignants je veux
donc être à leur côté sur l'ensemble de
ces petits moyens et grands problèmes du
quotidien qui leur pèseent sur leur
amour du métier qui reste pourtant
extrêmement élevé ce dont on doit se
féliciter et les en
remercier je voudrais mentionner
également ce que nous faisons pour les
aesh vous savez à quel point cette
profession fait parmi fait partie des
priorités pour nous car ils ont trop
souvent et trop longtemps évolué dans
des conditions précaires ce que nous
avons déjà fait c'est d'abord de créer
7000 postes d'aesh depuis 2022 3000 à
7ette rentrée nous avons également sur
le moyen terme procédé à une
augmentation de leurs conditions
salariales de 40 % et entre 10 et 13 %
de revalorisation salariale intervenue
dans la dernière tranche que nous venons
d'accorder qui est elle complémentaire à
la prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat qui a pu leur être alloué nous
avons également versé une majoration de
10 % de l'indemnité versée aux aesh
référents dont vous savez qu'ils
apportent un soutien précieux aux aesh
qui sont nouvellement nommés et je ne
reviens pas sur la mesure CDI que j'ai
déjà évoqué tout à l'heure nous
connaissons aujourd'hui les attentes
pour renforcer la reconnaissance de ce
métier porter la réflexion sur leur
statut les besoins qui sont les leurs en
matière d'accompagnement de formation et
nous nous sommes engagés à prendre à
Brasc ce chantier dans le cadre du du
déploiement de l'acte 2 de l'école
inclusive que je préfère peut-être
appeler avec vous l'école pour
tous sur le sujet du pacte je reviens
donc là à la problématique de nos
enseignants vous savez que ce ce
pacte nous procéderons à son évaluation
au cours du mois de février le Premier
ministre dans la déclaration de
politique générale s'y est engagé et
nous avons d'ors et déjà pris date avec
les organisations syndicales pour le 14
février prochain pour leur partager les
premiers éléments quantitatifs dont nous
disposons sur l'adoption par le corps
enseignant de cet outil qui est utile
qui est utile pour nous aider en matière
d'innovation pédagogique qui est utile
pour nous aider en matière
d'organisation notamment sur les
remplacements de courte durée qui est la
première mission prise par les
enseignants dans le cadre du du du pacte
mais aussi pour nous permettre de
diversifier leurs conditions
d'engagement aujourd'hui on sait que ce
Pact
est déjà autour du tiers des enseignants
adoptés avec des taux qui sont sur
lesquels je reviendrai le moment venu
qui sont supérieurs dans le second degré
à ceux qu'ils sont dans le premier degré
où ils permettent à des professeurs des
écoles de prendre des missions de
soutien scolaire notamment sur les
questions d'approfondissement de devoir
fait avec des pars de Pact qui sont là
aussi largement plébiscités par par ces
enseignants du prier
degré s'agissant des cours de théâtre
oui l'orientation nous a été demandée
par le Président de la République lors
de sa conférence de presse de rentrer et
nous avons déjà pris la décision de
travailler avec Rachid adati le
ministère de la Culture pour mobiliser
l'ensemble des associations et des
professionnels de de théâtre pour
fortifier les passerelles avec nos
établissements scolaires et dans le même
esprit nous ouvrirons là où il n'en
existe pas aujourd'hui des clubs de
théâtre pour permettre de premières
initiations à cette pratique pour nos
collégiens et nous ferons dans un second
temps en sorte que l'enseignement des
EAC permettent un meilleur
ordonnancement pour qu'on ait une
capacité à ne pas perdre sur le terrain
de la musique des arts plastiques mais
que nous fassions en même temps la place
attendue à ces activités de théâtre au
cœur des maquettes scolaires ainsi qu'à
l'enseignement de l'histoire des arts
comme là encore le président de la
République nous l'a demandé les
territoires ruraux vous avez raison de
mentionner la nécessité de continuer à
nous engager en leur faveur aujourd'hui
nos écoles rurales représentent 34 % des
écoles de la République pour 18 % des
élèves elles ont donc un taux
d'encadrement qui est favorable qui est
parfois dans certains territoires
jusqu'à deux points au-dessus de la
moyenne nationale en revanche nous
savons que nous devons donner une plus
grande visibilité notamment à 3 ans sur
les perspectives liées à la carte
scolaire nous savons que lorsqu'il y a
des perspectives démographiques qui sont
défavorables il faut mieux en anticiper
mieux mener la concertation avec les
élus et en même temps développer les
initiatives que nous avons développé
dans les zones d'éducation prioritaire
avec les cités éducatives en les
transposant de manière adaptée au
territoire eururaux c'est tout le sens
des territoires éducatifs ruraux nous en
aurons 191 à la rentrée prochaine qui
nous permettront là aussi de mettre en
coordination tous les services de l'État
avec les élus et les acteurs associé
pour proposer des solutions pédagogiques
qui soient innovantes et adapté comme
nous permet de le faire dans un autre
registre le CNR avec les 500 millions
d'euros sur 5 ans mobilisés pour faire
émerger y compris dans de très petits
établissements des projets pédagogiques
qui soitent innovants et qui permettent
le renouvellement du métier le
renouvellement aussi des savoirs de nos
enfants sur la question de l'éducation à
la sexualité je p au contraire qu'elle
est essentielle pour que nos enfants
puissent bien grandir l'éducation à la
sexualité c'est une dimension qui est
essentielle de la construction de
l'éducation du citoyen
là-dessus nous avons beaucoup trop
d'éterogénéité aujourd'hui dans la mise
en place des trois séances annuelles
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai saisi
le Conseil supérieur des programmes qui
doit mieux définir les contenus
d'enseignement et les compét qui sont
attendu aujourd'hui nous avons eu un
premier rendu de ces travaux et nous
avons demandé avec le DG SCO la
poursuite de ce travail il sera soumis à
la concertation au printemps ainsi qu'à
la rentrée scolaire 2024 de manière à ce
que les professeurs puissent avoir de la
visibilité des repères communs pour
mettre en œuvre une éducation à la vie
affective à la vie relationnelle à la
sexualité qui soit adapté au niveau et à
l'âge de nos élèves
s'agissant de l'évolution des taux
d'encadrement je voudrais là encore
revenir sur cette question qui est
importante et sur laquelle nous avons
déjà de premiers résultats probants je
reprenais les ratios l'évolution dans le
premier degré du nombre d'élèves par
classe est passé de
23,2 en 2017 à
21,5 à la rentrée de
2023 corrélativement le ratio P sur E a
augmenté nous avons plus de professeurs
devant nos élèves ce taux était de
5,54 en 2017 il est aujourd'hui
supérieur à 6 et sera à la rentrée de
2024 estimé à
6,03 et pour la première fois cette
année dans la loi de finances
2024 en revenant sur le schéma d'emploi
qui était initialement prévu nous
recréons des effectif dans le second
degré à hauteur de
574 d'entre eux ces moyensl ils sont
notamment mis au service de la mise en
place des groupes de niveau dont je
redis que CEN est en rien une
renonciation au collège unique que ça
n'est en rien une mise en place de
classe de niveau qui créerait un système
à plusieurs vitesses mais qu'au
contraire ce que nous cherchons à faire
c'est de remettre plus de plasticité
dans le système et de valiser les
progrès effectués par nos enfants la
question m'a été posée tout à l'heure
non je ne fais pas de différence entre
des groupes de niveau et des groupes de
besoins et même des groupes de progrès
et il me semble que la sémantique en
effet est importante et peut tout à fait
évoluer en la
matière aujourd'hui ces groupes de
progrès ces groupes de besoins ont été
mise en œuvre avec succès dans des pays
comme la Suisse dans des pays comme le
Danemark à l'inverse nous savons que les
classes de niveau
ell ne marchent pas et que partout où
cela a été expérimenté ce sont des
impasses dans lesquels les personnes se
sont trouvées donc nous voulons le
remettre en marche cet ascenseur
scolaire et on ne peut pas observer et
se navrer de l'évolution des résultats
PISA sans tenter autre chose la folie
serait de reproduire toujours les mêmes
méthodes face aux mêmes problèmes et
d'espérer un résultat différent donc oui
nous voulons innover nous voulons le
faire avec les chefs d'établissement
avec les enseignants qui disposeront de
tout notre appui avec les cellules mises
en place par les rectorats et les daenes
avec le vademcom développé par la dgco
et avec le DGESCO tour qui sera livré
par les équipes d'doard gefry et qui
permettront d'avoir au plus près des
territoires une analyse des besoins et
si nécessaire de réallouer un certain
nombre d'entre eux je soulligne que dans
les 2230 et 2330 ETP que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure une enveloppe de
830 sera spécifiquement allouée aux
établissements qui compteent le plus
grand nombre d'élèves en
difficulté sur le sujet des valeurs de
la
République c'est pour moi un enjeu
absolument majeur et je me félicite des
résultats que j'ai pu partagé en la
matière dans le cadre du cdsn récent
autour du président de la République
clairement la fermeté paye Gabriel Atal
a pris cette décision d'interdire le
port de laaba et du camis et nous avons
une baisse absolument drastique des
atteintes à la laïcité lié au port des
tenues et des signes contraires à la loi
de 2004 don je je rappelle que nous
fêterons le 15 mars prochain le 20e
annivers et nous aurons à cœur de le
fêter de manière digne et engagée cet
anniversaire y compris à travers une
initiative que j'ai pu aborder avec la
présidente du conseil des sages de la
laïcité Dominique Schnapper consistant à
lancer un groupe de travail dans les
établissements privés pour nous assurer
d'une application pleine entière
effective de ce principe de laïcité dans
ses établissements privés nous
surveillons comme le la sur le feu les
autres atteintes à la laïcité les
violences verbales l'apologie du
terrorisme le refus de se soumettre à
certains enseignement sur tous ces plans
là aussi la réponse des équipes
pédagogiques des chefs d'établissement
est à la hauteur et je voudrais vous
donner ces ces chiffresl parmi les 1812
cas d'atteintte qui ont été remontés au
cours du mois de novembre 40 % ont donné
lieu à des dépôts de plaines 208 mesures
conservatoires interdiction d'accès à
l'établissement ont été prononcé et 120
élèves ont été exclus définitivement
nous continuerons dans cette fermeté et
sur ces sujets-là comme sur les sujets
de la promotion de la place des femmes
du combat pour l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes le combat en faveur
de la lutte contre toutes les
discriminations je pense avoir
suffisamment proué dans mon dans mon
mandat ministériel des 20 derniers mois
mon engagement absolu sur ces thématique
JUSE Jau Qatar quand il a fallu aller
les
porter sur la crise des voocation elle
est importante et c'est ce qui nous
conduit
aujourd'hui à répondre à la commande que
nous a passé le président de la
République d'une révision des mécaniques
de formation initial pour en effet
anticiper le passage du concours de Bac
+ 5 5 pardon à bac + 3 en créant des
parcours de Licence à la fois pour le
professorat des écoles et pour les
professeurs certifiés et en faisant en
sorte aussi à cette occasion que les
deux années de Master M1 et M2
correspondent à un meilleur panachage
entre la finalisation de la formation
disciplinaire et la prise en compte des
besoins spécifiques liés à la pratique
et à la gestion de la vie de classe
c'est extrêmement important cette
réforme est structurante le président de
la République a dit sa volonté de voir
émerger ces nouvelles écoles normales du
21e siècle et nous reviendrons là aussi
avec des propositions étayées que nous
sommes en train d'arbitrer avec le
Premier
ministre sur les
sujets de
euh de de de politique salariale je je
pense avoir déjà
répondu il me manque une réponse oui les
sujets de mixité pardon sur le sur la la
mixité sociale et scolaire je voulais
ajouter à ma réponse précédente
l'attention qui sera la mienne non
seulement à la qualité des contrôles
financiers administratifs pédagogique
sur les établissements privés mais aussi
au fait que l'ensemble des dispositions
qui ont été prévues par le protocole de
mai 23 signé avec le sec secrétariat
général de l'Enseignement Catholique
soit pleinement mise en œuvre ça veut
dire le suivi dans les conditions
d'accès aux établissements ça veut dire
de la transparence dans l'accueil des
élèves à besoin particuliers y compris
les élèves en situation de handicap et
ça veut dire aussi aller au bout de nos
engagements plus 50 % en 5 ans sur le
nombre d'établissements qui proposent
des contributions familiales modulées en
fonction des revenus des familles et
aussi un engagement de doubler le taux
d'élèves boursi partout où les
établissements peuvent disposer des
mêmes aides fournies par les
collectivités locales sur toutes ces
dispositions qui forment ce plan
d'action nous avons déjà engagé les
conversations et nous poursuivrons de
manière à ce qu'il soi appliqué de
manière pleine et
entière merci madame la ministre pour
ses premières réponses à aux différentes
interpellations et interrogations et
nous allons reprendre maintenant avec
les
orateurs pour une minute et je vous
rappelle mes chers collègues que nous
avons 40 inscrits donc c'est une minute
et pas une seconde de plus merci
beaucoup donc Cécile rilac merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre depuis
2017 notre majorité a déployé des
efforts de grande ampleur pour améliorer
la scolarisation des élèves en situation
de handicap et des élèves à besoins
particuliers permettre à notre école de
la République d'être pleinement
inclusive est un chantier prioritaire et
c'est sur ce chantier que je souhaite
vous interroger pour relever le défi de
la lutte contre les inégalités les
retours du terrain font remonter de
nombreuses problématiques liées au
manque de moyens matériels et humains
aux difficultés de recrutement des aesh
à la formation souvent insuffisante des
personnels enseignants comme
non-enseignants ou encore aux classes
parfois surchargées qui ne favorisent
pas une prise en charge optimale des
élèves à besoins particuliers madame la
ministre face à ces difficultés il nous
faut déclencher ce fameuse acte 2 de
l'école inclusive que vous avez appelé
pacte pour tous conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République exprimé dans le lors de la
Conférence nationale du handicap en
avril 2023 cette CNH a prévu une série
de mesures destinées à renforcer la
dimension inclusive de notre école nous
devons avancer sur ce sujet en actant
des mesures comme la remise en cause des
piales ou le rapprochement entre le
médico-social
et est votre feuille de route je vous
REM Roger
chudau
merciad
alors merci Madame présidente madame la
ministre j'ai sous les yeux une offre
d'emploi recherche de professeurs de
français urgent collège Hubert filet de
Bracieux c'est sur le bon coin voyez ça
fait 3 mois que ce collège n'a pas de
professeur de français donc ma question
pose sur le remplacement de courte durée
et même de longue durée dans le second
degré le pacte vous devriez tout
doucement commencer à à le percevoir ne
peut pas fonctionner parce qu'il est
affecté d'un défaut de conception on ne
peut pas faire réaliser une liigation de
moyens par des seuls volontaires quand
il y a 100 professeurs absents et
seulement 30 volontaires le taux de non
couverture est évidemment de 70 % donc
ceci porte atteinte au bon
fonctionnement du service public et à
son image aussi dans le privé évidemment
c'est plus simple puisque
l'établissement bénéficie d'un petit
volant contractuel qu'ils utilisent à
leur gré c'est très bien ça n'est pas
possible pour le public alors la
question est très simple madame la
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
assurer comme le souhaite le président
de la République 100 % de remplacement
immédiatement merci merci monsieur le
député Anne brenierra
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre à la fin de la procédure 2023
de parcours sup sur 917000 bacheliers
148 étaient sans affectation ils étaient
160 en 2022 239 en 2021 591 en 2020 ces
chiffres sont en constante amélioration
grâce notamment au travail des
professionnels investi dans les
commissions académiques d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur que je tiens à
saluer il monte néanmoins que des jeunes
bacheliers ont toujours des difficultés
à trouver les formations qui leur
conviennent certaines filières sont
largement surdemandées quand d'autres
manquent de candidats malgré les troisè
prépas métier et autres stages le
déséquilibre persiste entre le nombre de
candidats et les places disponibles dans
de nombreuses formations souvent par
manque de connaissance des opportunités
d'orientation qu'en est-il de
l'accompagnement personnalisé tout au
long de l'année de nos lycéens notamment
au mois de juin et plus en amont que
pouveznous vous nous que pouvez-nous
vous dire non bref que pouvez-vous nous
dire pardon de la mise en œuvre de la
découverte des métiers au collège qui
est là pour lutter contre les a prioris
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Rodrigo
Arenas madame la présidente madame la
ministre si l'on en croit les sondages
le porort de l'uniforme semble bien
faire fureur auprès des plus de 55 ans
par contre les élèves c'est-à-dire ceux
qui sont concernés sont beaucoup moins
enthousiastes à Marseille au Man ou à
plouisi les jeunes et la communauté
éducative ont clairement dit non à cette
expérience voulue par votre ministère du
coup nous attendons avec impatience la
liste de votre centaine d'établissements
volontaires pour cette expérience car
vous semblez un peu à la peine ma
question est assez simple ces tenu coûte
200 € et vous vous êtes engagé à ne pas
faire payer les familles où alors où
allez-vous trouver cet argent si cette
année vous prenez en charge ce coût pour
les établissements qui participent à
l'expérience allez-vous prendre en
charge peut-être d'ailleurs de façon
rétroactive le coût des tenu unique
actuellement prise en charge par les
familles dans les écoles publiques qui
impos depuis longtemps par exemple comme
en Guadeloupe à la marque cinique ou
encore à la Réunion enfin si l'uniforme
est imposée partout en France en 2026
comme vous le préconisez où allez-vous
trouver les 2 milliards d'euros que cela
va coûter merci merci monsieur le député
Maxime minot merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je voudrais vous
parler de la carte scolaire et de la
qualité d'enseignement je bien
évidemment parler de mon état mon
département de loise et particulièrement
de la circonscription dans laquelle je
suis élu et vous exposer deux cas
concrets de fermeture de classe neuf
fermetures sont annoncées dans la
circonscription et certaines fermetures
semble légitime de par bien évidemment
la baisse démographique et je n'ai pas
pour habitude d'aller au combat en tout
cas de défendre l'indéfendable cependant
deux cas concrets un premier cas concret
école Jean Gautier de scilgand
actuellement à une moyenne raisonnable
d'un peu plus de 21 élèves par classe ce
qui passerait après fermeture à plus de
25 élèves par classe ce qui déjà ne
respecte pas l'engagement du président
de la République avec les 24 élèves par
classe partout sur le territoire
national mais la particularité est que
dans cette école il y a plus de 100
heures de présence à es par semaine soit
près d'une dizaine es présente sur
l'établissement ce qui reviendrait donc
à après fermeture à des classes de plus
d'une trentaine de personnes ce ConA
concret école du parc d'etz actuellement
21,6 par classe et seront à 24 élèves
par classe après fermeture alors vous
allez me dire on est dans les clou mais
particulier mes particularités également
de cet établissement qui a été victime
d'une fonte de ses élèves non pas
uniquement duû à la baisse démographique
mais par l'implantation d'un
établissement privé sous contrat à 400 m
l'école doit donc justement l'école
publique doit apporter un service de
qualité dans un cadre serein et apaisé
ma question est donc simple quand
l'éducation nationale va-t-elle se f au
cas par cas pour fixer une carte
scolaire juste je vous monsieur le
vice-président vous avez bénéficié d'un
temps totalement
indu le fait d'avoir exposé votre
situation se tenit bien
voilà donc je m'excuse auprès des
collègues de ne pas
avoir réagi suffisamment
tôt voilà
donc
que voilà que que
les voilà que les autres ne ne ne
pensent pas que ne s'en inspire pas ne
s'inspire pas complètement
de Virginie
lanlau merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre votre prédécesseur a fait
des annonces fortes afin d'améliorer le
niveau et le bien-être des élèves qui
ont suscité une large adhésion des
Français que je je ne peux que saluer il
appartient désormais des mettre en
application notamment concernant
l'organisation des groupes de niveau en
français et mathématiques au collège la
volonté de prendre en compte les
difficultés de chacun pour permettre
l'épanouissement et la réussite de tous
est est salutaire mais réclame dans
chacun de nos établissements une
organisation fine et des moyens
importants d'où découlent deux questions
simples quelle marge de manœuvre
entendez-vous laisser aux établissements
pour mettre en place ces groupes et à
quelle hauteur seront-ils accompagnés
par le ministère tant en moyen RH
qu'organisationnel dans mon département
m et haute scène le directeur académique
a pu travailler avec chacun des collèges
afin d'évaluer et répartir les besoins
permettant la mise en œuvre des groupes
de niveau avec une priorité donné au
groupe 1 soit pour les enfants les plus
en difficulté cette montée en puissance
progressive serait parfaitement
compréhensible au vu du temps nécessaire
pour évaluer les besoins financiers RH
que la création de groupe de niveau
suppose mais elle pose du coup pour moi
avec encore plus d'acuité la question de
l'adaptation locale merci madame la
députée Julien
audoule merci madame la Présidente
madame la ministre en juillet 2017
Emmanuel Macron faisait la promesse
qu'aucune classe ne serait contrainte à
la fermeture en milieu rural il y a
quelques jours encore dans l'hémicycle
vous disiez je ferai de la place de
l'école dans nos ruralité l'une de mes
priorités madame la ministre que
dites-vous aujourd'hui aux parents
d'élèves et aux enseignants de
villeevallier malelgrand Joan rosois
veryon vinvelaguillard vov suonne Domas
montage civil Gardin saint-clémment
essence qui voit dangereusement la
nouvelle carte scolaire faire
disparaître l'une de leur classe en 10
an dans mon département de Lyonne 232
classes ont été purement et simplement
supprimées la qualité de l'instruction
donnée à nos enfants et je dis bien à
tous nos enfants pas seulement ce des
quartiers dit prioritaires ne doit pas
être dicté par des ratios des
statistiques ou de la comptabilité quand
allez-vous arrêter votre politique de
cascolaire quand allez-vous arrêter de
fragiliser la ruralité quand allez-vous
arrêter la logique comptable au
détriment de l'intérêt éducatif de nos
enfants le seul qui compte merci
monsieur le député Sophie met
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre l'Assemblée nationale a lancé à
l'initiative de mon collègue Yannick
moner une évaluation des politiques
publiques pour favoriser l'accès à la
culture des personnes en situation de
handicap j'en suis corapporteur nous
interrogerons notamment le bureau de
l'école inclusive de la dgsco rattaché
au ministère de l'Éducation nationale
sans empiéter sur cette future audition
j'aimerais profiter de votre présence
parmi nous pour vous entendre sur la
place donnée à l'accès de la culture
dans le cadre de l'école inclusive que
pouvez-vous nous dire madame la ministre
sur ce que vous évaluez et comptez
accomplir sur ce sujet pardon au sens
large en matière de formation des
enseignants sur les questions de
l'accessibilité des outils pédagogiques
à leur disposition pour favoriser
l'accès à la culture des élèves en
situation de handicap quelle
constattiz-vous et quelles sont vos
ambitions je vous remercie merci madame
la députée Fatia
keli merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre j'avais prévu de vous poser
une question sur sur les groupes de
niveau mais je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire de d'énormes contrevérités sur le
programme d'éducation à la vie affective
et à la sexualité il vous a été remis le
14 décembre sur le bureau du ministre de
l'éducation nationale un programme voté
à l'unanimité du Conseil supérieur des
programmes ce programme c'est 6 mois
d'audition depuis le mois de juin où
Papia nous a saisi jusqu'au mois de
décembre ce travail a été un travail
colossal et remis sur votre bureau il
n'est à aucun moment prévu de
retravailler sur ce programme comme vous
vous venez de le dire le CSP n'a pas été
saisi jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
puisque j'en fais partie donc ma
question c'est que voulez-vous faire de
ce programme si vous voulez l'enterrer
faut nous le dire
clairement deuxème question par rapport
au groupe de niveau je les moyens sont
constants la marge de la D de la la
dotation globale horaire est utilisé par
les chefs d'établissement comme une
souplesse pour l'établissement je vous
donne un exemple enène Sam dit dans ma
circonscription une fois qu'on a fait
les groupes de niveau et bien il reste
plus de d'heures il reste plus d'heures
pour faire les groupes de langues à 20
il reste plus d'heur pour faire du latin
et du grec donc ma question c'est
comment comptez-vous faire
oui madame merci madame la députée comme
j'avais laissé dépasser
Maxime je l'ai dit j'ai pris
l'initiative de faire laisser dépasser
un par groupe donc après vous choisissez
qui vous voulez voilà
donc maintenant comme pour l'instant les
orateurs avent tous tenus dans une
minute je n'ai pas laissé enfin il n'y
avait pas lieu que j'applique la
clémence Jérémy Patrier
lus merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'aimerais vous
interrogeréoute
pasad bon oui vasy j'aimerais vous
interroger sur la question des écoles
rurales qui sont les piliers de nos
territoires ruraux ell contribuent au
dynamisme de nos communes rurales et
représente souvent le dernier service
public en avril dernier il y a près d'un
an la première ministre a annoncé une
nouvelle méthode conseil de la
concertation carte scolaire à 3 ans
forceé de constater que dans de nombreux
départements comme le VI comme le mien
dans le Calvados ces conseils de la
concertation n'ont pas été tenus et nous
n'avons toujours pas de visibilité à 3
ans de la carte scolaire ma question est
simple à partir de quand ces conseils de
la concertation devront obligatoirement
se tenir et à partir de quand la carte
scolaire à 3 ans sera-t-elle mise en
place est-ce que pour les fermetures
annoncées pour la rentrée 2024 sa
méthode cette méthode sera mise en place
partout en France je vous remerci merci
monsieur le député Philippe
fet merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le 5 décembre dernier Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Gabriel Attal alors
en charge de l'éducation national
présenter son plan d'action intitulé Le
choc des savoirs un objectif qui préside
celui d'offrir un accompagnement
personnaliser aux élèves et ainsi les
doter de savoirs fondamentaux
nécessaires pour affronter leur vie
professionnelle vous avez souhaité vous
saisir de ces questions primordiales et
poursivre dans cette voie a raison
cependant comme toute réforme elles sont
accompagnées de questionnements sur le
terrain plus précisément le choc des
savoirs annonceinttroduction de groupe
de niveau en français en mathématiques à
ce propos des enseignants de sa pas dans
ma circonscription ont fait part de
leurs interrogations je pense notamment
aux enseignants du collège enjores
d'établee sur mer
enseignants certifiés pour pour les
aides spécialisés les enseignements
adaptés la scolarisation des élèves en
situation de handicap j'ai pu constater
combien ceux-ci ont besoin d'un suivi
individualisé la secpa constitue
d'ailleurs une sorte de groupe de
besoins permettant aux élèves en
difficulté de progresser en toute
sérénité aussi les enseignants se
doivent se demandent si le choc des
savoirs s'appliquera au SE pas et sous
quelle modalité ces élèves seront-ils
intégrés au groupe de niveau en
mathématique et en français merci
monsieur le député Sarah
Legrin merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre tout d'abord je salue vos
efforts pour mettre en mouvement les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale qui
sont descendus dans la rue aujourd'hui
encore après la semaine dernière pour
demander votre démission avant cette
probable démission j'aimerais vous
interroger au sujet de l'école privée
que vous avez particulièrement mise à
l'honneur dès votre prise de fonction
école privée qui devrait selon vous
continuer à bénéficier des fonds publics
au motif qu'elle participerait de
l'école de la République alors la
République implique le refus de
discriminer les individus en fonction de
l'origine sociale du genre de
l'orientation sexuelle de la religion en
conséquence comptez-vous contraindre ces
établissements privés qui reposent
alement sur un tri social et scolaire
comme Stanislas par exemple à remplir
des objectifs d' mixité scolaire et
sociale et si oui comment comptez-vous
interdire cette aberration heureusement
fort rare des classes non mixtes qui
existent dans certains établissements
privés sous contrat comme Stanislas par
exemple quelle sanction prévoyez-vous
pour les établissements privés qui
véhiculent des stéréotypes sexistes et
homophobes et enfraignent la laïcité
jusque dans leurs enseignements et leurs
règlement intérieurs comme Stanislas par
exemple je vous remercie merci madame la
députée Isabelle
priigo merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre je veux avant tout saluer
ici l'action des enseignants et du
personnel éducatif qui se battent tous
les jours dans des conditions parfois
difficiles pour nos enfants de France
avec passion et conviction les
dédoublements de classe les nouveaux
moyens allués ne sont pas pour la
ruralité il ne s'agit pas d'opposer
milieuain urbain pardon et rural mais
dans ma circonscription de cémarne une
une nouvelle classe de petite commune va
encore fermer à la rentrée prochaine
pour vos services un élève une place
mais pour ces communes c'est tout un
écosystème qui vit grâce à l'école les
parents tremblent dans l'attente de la
confirmation de la sentence les mèes se
questionnent sur la façon dont ils vont
organiser l'école les classes se
retrouvent souvent à trois niveaux ou
alors les écoles sont regroupées
obligeant les parents à faire plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres le pire estant
que si l'annonce de la décision
intervient au premier semestre il faut
attendre juin voir la rentrée de
septembre pour avoir la confirmation ou
non cette fermeture alors ma question
est simple quand comptez-vous prendre en
compte les spécificités de la ruralité
dans votre modèle de gestion de
fermeture de place vous remci mer madame
la députée Caroline
Parmentier merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je veux attirer
aujourd'hui votre attention sur les
grandes difficultés que rencontrent les
élèves des lycées professionnels pour
trouver des stages dans les entreprises
14 semaines de stage obligatoire en CAP
et 22 semaines pour le cursus bac pro
ces élèves sont majoritairement mineurs
beaucoup d'entreprises refusent de
prendre des mineurs plusieurs
responsables d'établissement mais aussi
élèves et familles de ma circonscription
du pas decaléis m'ont alerté j'ai
également rencontré cette difficulté
avec mon propre fils qui qui était en
bac pro métier de la sécurité c'est à la
fois injuste et démotivant pour beaucoup
qui ne bénéficient ni de passe droit ni
de piston le système ne fonctionne pas
que
proposez-vous merci madame la députée
gradiella
melkur merci
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en décembre dernier nous avons
présenté avec ma collègue Francesca
paskini un rapport relatif à
l'adaptation de l'école aux enjeux
climatiques que cette commission nous
avait confié notre rapport traitait de
l'ensemble de ce vaste sujet de la
nécessaire rénovation du Bapti scolaire
à la question de l'alimentation de
l'introduction de la sobriété ou encore
des transports et de manière
significatif de l'aspect pédagogique en
la matière nous préconisons notamment de
renforcer les dimensions transversale et
concrète de l'éducation au développement
durable dans les programmes d'instituer
une validation de parcours obligatoire
en classe de 3e pour cette matière ou
encore de sanctuariser un temps de
classe dehors et d'inciter les
enseignants à cette pratique qui emporte
de nombreux aspects positifs pour
l'enfant aussi madame la ministre je
souhaiterais connaître l'engagement qui
sera le vôtre sur cette dernière
question et plus globalement l'action
que vous souhaitez mettre en place pour
que l'école puisse répondre à l'urgence
climatique et être motrice des
transitions nécessaires je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Fabrice l
viigoureux merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre il y a quelques jours
avec ma collègue Annie je neevard nous
avons présenté ici même les conclusions
d'un de la mission d'information sur
l'apprentissage de la lecture les
chiffres sont très alarmants vous les
connaissez je n'en citerai qu'un celui
de la journée défense citoyenneté où
seul deux élèves sur trois deux jeunes
sur trois présentent des acquis solides
en matière de lecture et de
compréhension pour lutter contre cet
état de fait nous sommes absolument
convaincus que beaucoup de réponses se
trouvent au cœur même des classes et de
l'enseignement nous avons donc formulé
35 préconisations que nous viendrons
prochainement vous présenter dans le
détail sur les méthodes d'apprentissage
en classe de CP sur la refondte de la
formation initiale des enseignants sur
la labellisation et le renouvellement
complet des manuels de lecture en CP sur
le soutien aux bibliothèques sur le
développement de la lecture partagée en
dehors de l'école l'enseignement de la
lecture madame la ministre est le plus
fondamental tant en découle tous les
autres alors nous souhaiterions
connaître
votre quelle sera votre action en la
matière je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député Sophie talier polian merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
quand vous parlez de nixité sociale vos
propos sonnent faux vous avez beau
égrené vos éléments de langage vous ne
convainquez personne car vos mots ne
résiste pas au fait quand vous évoquez
la baisse du nombre d'élèvres par classe
en moyenne ah bah oui en moyenne mais en
moyenne seulement parce que les
dédoublements de quelques classes ont
fait mécaniquement monter le nombre
d'élèves des autres classes c'est ce que
nous observons sur le terrain si vous
étiez allé dans une école publique ou un
collège public ces derniers mois ces
dernières années pas seulement ces
derniers jours vous le sauriez vous
sauriez aussi que la réforme des groupes
de niveau est non seulement néfaste mais
qu'elle est aussi impossible à mettre en
œuvre aujourd'hui avec les moyens qui
sont donnés au collège sans supprimer
des options type latin ou des
demi-groupes notamment qui permettent
d'avoir accès aux travaux pratiques en
science donc vos réformes sont néfastes
et aujourd'hui impossible à mettre en
œuvre encore une fois je le répète vos
mots ne résistent pas au
faits merci madame la députée Géraldine
Banier madame la ministre concernant les
groupes de niveau voici ce qui me
remonte d'un collège public en Bretagne
une principale de collège constatant une
DGH ne permettant pas de créer ses
groupes au-delà des deux classes par
niveau existantes a annoncer aux
enseignants qu'il n'y aurait plus ni
latin ni allemand ni groupe de sciences
expérimental à la prochaine rentrée une
la professeur de lettrre classique de ce
même établissement au cœur brisé alerte
dans un contexte aussi concurrentiel que
le nôtre avec la force du privé dans
cette région on voudrait tuer
l'enseignement public qu'on ne s'y
prendrait pas autrement la professeur
évoque aussi les déplacements induits
d'enseignants entre établissement que va
induire la mise en barrette des cours
dans ce petit établissement risque sur
la route surcharge de travail aussi
pouvez-vous madame la ministre assurer
cette professeur de latin à
l'investissement reconnu qui m'a confié
son envie de jeter l'éponge et nous vous
assurer de la volonté de votre ministère
de préserver ses enseignements latin
allemand gage de réussite et dont la
rigueur pris et notamment par les
établissements privés doit rester bien
évidemment accessible à tous il s'agit
de puissant levier d'ascenseur social à
défendre et j'en suis le fruit merci
madame la
députée madame la ministre c'est à vous
pour cette première salbe de questions
et pour vos
réponses merci madame la Présidente
alors sur le la question de l'école
inclusive je l'évoqué tout à l'heure on
doit absolument réussir cet acte 2 vous
avez en tête les 12 mesures qui ont été
annoncées par le Président de la
République je vais évidemment pas toutes
les citer mais je voudrais vraiment
revenir sur les trois axes principaux le
premier c'est le déploiement d'un grand
plan de formation initiale et continu
des équipes pédagogiques le deuxième
c'est l'amélioration des fonctions
d'aesh qui pourront travailler plus et
mieux et on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
y compris sur le temps méridien avec
avec la prise en charge par l'État de
leur temps de travail ou encore
l'amélioration aussi du travail mené
avec les équipes médico-soal qui seront
positionnés auprès des écoles des
collèges des lycées pour intervenir en
soutien des élèves et des équipes
pédagogiques et je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure au-delà d'une meilleure
organisation collective d'un
renforcement des conditions de travail
pour nos aesh c'est bien une
problématique globale
d'accessibilité y compris matériel y
compris numérique que nous devons
garantir pour faire réussir cette école
pour tous sur le sujet qui est lié de
l'accessibilité à la culture pour les
élèves qui sont en situation de de
handicap aujourd'hui on est face à deux
situations qui sont assez différentes
dans les établissements on a aujourd'hui
la part collectif du Pass Culture qui
est un outil absolument majeur qui
permet aujourd'hui avec avec 57 millions
d'euros mobilisés aux établissements
d'avoir les moyens pour emmener les
élèves les embarquer dans ces activités
culturelles en revanche ça n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui pour les IME j'ai
demandé à la dgsco d'y travailler et de
faire en sorte qu'à tout âge scolaire de
la 6e à la terminale les enfants en
situation de handicap puissent
bénéficier de cet accès à la culture et
je sais les professionnels de la culture
extrêmement engagés à nos côtés pour
garantir cet
accès sur la question des remplacements
vous avez raison de mettre en avant
cette problématique qui est très
importante et qui constitue à la fois le
symptôme de difficulté d'organisation
mais aussi des pertes de Chan pour nos
élèves nous avons attaqué comme aucun
autre gouvernement auparavant la
question des remplacement de courte
durée en agissant à la fois sur
l'organisation not amment de la
formation continue qui nous permet de
ramener à 25 % seulement aujourd'hui le
volume de cause endogène généré par
notre propre organisation totalement
indépendamment des professeurs et de
leur situation et aujourd'hui c'est je
prends les tableaux de bord qui ont été
créés spécialement à cette fin c'est
aujourd'hui
11,52 % des heures qui sont remplacées
contre seulement 4 ,5 % soit un
triplement des heures remplacées sur une
année calendaire seulement si on
considère le dernier trimestre de
l'année 22 et le dernier trimestre de
l'année 2023 et dans le même temps on
peut aussi mentionner le recul des
heures non
assurées à hauteur de un petit peu plus
d'un point sur la même période c'est
l'ensemble que nous devons continu
continuer à améliorer j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le succès du pacte et le fait
que la miss mission RCD qui est
prioritaire dans l'allocation des pars
de Pact aujourd'hui permettait déjà de
dégager un volant d'Ur supérieur à 1,3
million et nous devons aller plus loin
en ce sens je ferai au Premier ministre
et au président de la République des 7
semaines des propositions en ce sens sur
le sujet de la découverte des métiers
d'abord d'où paraitton d'une situation
où à la fin du collège nos élèves ne
connaissaient en moyenne que 10 métiers
alors que nous voulons qu'ils en
connaissent au moins 50 c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a développé cet
enseignement de découverte des métier
qui est déployé partout et qui le sera
entre la 5e et la et la 3e pardon à la
rentrée de 2024 sur la découverte des
métiers il y a deux mesures il y a deux
temps spécifiques une phase
d'expérimentation et une phase dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui de
généralisation avec au moins un corps
ordonnateur de cet enseignement par
collège des actions sont entreprises
avec des rencontres de professionnels
mais aussi des visites d'entreprise et
c'est exactement la même logique que
nous voulons arriver à développer avec
la mise en place des stage de seconde 15
jours de stage en fin de seconde pour
lesquels il y a déjà un volume d'offre
de stage supérieur à 200000 aujourd'hui
et une plateforme sur le site un jeune
une solution qui permettra à tous les
élèves de trouver des opportunités de
stage leur permettant d'améliorer leur
découverte des métiers et leurs
conditions
d'orientation sur le sujet de la prise
en charge de la tenue commune
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes que dans une
phase d'expérimentation je le rappelle
il n'est en aucun cas à ce stade décidé
d'une généralisation don la
soutenabilité pour l'instant du coût de
cette mesure elle doit s'observer à à
l'échelle de cette expérimentation pour
laquelle l'État s'est engagé à prendre
50 % du coût en même temps que la
collectivité pour un total d'environ à
peu près 100 écoles ce qui justifie un
enregistrement de l'ordre de 2 millions
d'euros dans les moyens du FIB qui
accompagnent ces ces établissements
aujourd'hui on voit que
l'expérimentation commence à monter en
puissance avec une volonté de s'engager
de plus d'une centaine d'écoles et des
établissement et la dynamique qui va se
poursuivre et que nous regarderons de
très près pour voir ses impacts de la
tenue unique sur les inégalités sociales
sur le climat scolaire et sur aussi le
sentiment d'appartenance d'unité qui
peut être procuré aux élèves des
établissements
concernés sur le sujet de la sisine du
du CSP je je j'ai eu deux échanges
nourris avec Marc che Sheringham et
c'est fait partie des questions que j'ai
pu évoquer madame la députée avec lui
aujourd'hui le travail n'est pas achevé
par le CSP sur ces ces dimensions là et
nous avons eu à l'échelle de la DGESCO
des échanges de travail nourri ce
programme n'est pas encore publié et
nous avons demandé un certain nombre
d'évolution de retravail de discussions
qui vont se poursuivre et qui suivront
le cours normal relatif à ces travaux
sur le
sujet de de de la carte scolaire et de
de des taux d'encadrement moi je
voudrais quand même rappeler une réalité
qui est que aujourd'hui on a en France
le maillage territorial le plus fin en
terme de nombre d'écoles on a 15000
écoles de une à trois classes il faut
avoir en tête cette richesse ce maillage
cette densité et le préserver au mieux
de ce que nous de ce que nous pouvons
faire
s'agissant spécifiquement pardon des
territoires ruraux moi je veux rappeler
que les écoles en ruralité forment 34 %
du parc d'élèves d'école publiqu pour 18
% des élèves donc on voit qu'il y a un
taux d'encadrement qui est favorable et
qui en certaines collectivités et même
de de points supérieur à ce qu'il est
dans la moyenne nationale et je veux
plus largement que cette question
des plus largement sur cette question
des taux d'encadrement rappeler les
efforts qui ont été les nôtres au niveau
du prer degré en zone d'éducation
prioritaire mais plus largement les
évolution favorable que connaît
aujourd'hui ce ratio je peux les
détailler en 2017 le ratio était d'à peu
près 24 élèves par classe en maternelle
il est de 21,7 en 2023 dans les écoles
élémentaires il était de 23 élèves par
classe en 2017 il est aujourd'hui au
plan national de 21 élèves par classe et
ces évolutions favorables elles sont oui
c'est vrai encore plus fortes bien sûr
en zone d'éducation prioritaire nous
sommes passés de 20
à
17,4 nous sommes passés en zone REP plus
pardon ce que je viens de dire c'est
pour les zones REP plus et en zone
d'éducation prioritaire nous sommes
passés de 23 à
18,4 ayons bien conscience que ce sont
là des résultats très significatifs qui
ont été obtenus sur le
primaire je reprends le fil des autres
questions
sur le
sujet de la voie professionnelle au-delà
de la refonte du cycle terminal nous
nous attachons aussi à améliorer les
conditions d'insertion et et les liens
avec les entreprises je pense notamment
à la mise en place des bureaux des
entreprises pour permettre d'appuyer nos
lycéens dans leur recherche de stage et
animer les liens entre un établissement
et son tissu
économique environnant on met aussi au
point en place on le déploie le
dispositif ambition emploi par lequel le
jeune n'est plus laissé à lui-même en
juillet après son bac il est recontacté
par l'établissement et il peut être
inscrit de septembre à décembre de
l'année suivante pour faire des stages
ou bien pour parfaire sa formation c'est
tout cet accompagnement que nous sommes
en train de leur apporter à nos jeunes
pour favoriser ces conditions
d'orientation sur l'apprentissage de la
lecture monsieur le député le vigoureux
vous avez raison d'insister sur cette
thématique qui est essentielle et je
sais le travail que vous avez mené avec
la députée Genevard dans le cadre de
votre mission sur l'apprentissage de la
lecture aujourd'hui cette lecture c'est
évidemment l'un des apprentissages
fondamentaux sur lesquels s'appuie notre
scolarité et on a besoin d'en sécuriser
la maîtrise tout ça est essentiel on a
aujourd'hui des progressions comme le
montrent les évaluations de CP de CE1 de
CM1 mais aussi en 6e et en 4e mais on
doit continuer c'est le sens du
dédoublement des classes en Rep et en
Rep plus que je viens d'évoquer mais
c'est aussi le sens de la révision des
programmes sur l'ensemble des cycles 1 2
3 4 dans le cadre du choc des savoirs et
de la labellisation des manuels de
français avec la contribution financière
de l'État que j'voqu
tout à
l'heure sur le sujet des secpas les
sepas ne vont pas être concerné par la
mise en place des groupes de niveau je
veux le redire elles ne sont pas
concerné par ce dispositif la question
de l'égalité des chances y étant abordé
de manière tout à fait spécifique avec
l'attention qu'elle requière pour ses
élèves à besoins éducatifs particuliers
s'agissant des instances de concer
et de dialogue Mise en place avec les
élus des territoires ruraux je confirme
qu'elles ont bien été créées depuis la
fin de l'année 2023 mais j'ai conscience
qu'aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas encore
mises en œuvre de manière assez homogène
sur l'ensemble du territoire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans les T
prochains jours j'écrirai au recteur et
au daen pour qu'on ait une mise en œuvre
effectif et totalement homogène à
travers les territoires de cette
nouvelle instance dans tous les
département qui est absolument majeur
dans la conduite de notre politique
éducative en faveur des territoires
ruraux je pense là encore qu'il me
manque une une
réponse euh
oui
mais madame la ministre si vous n'avez
pas répondu à la totalité des questions
sachez qu'il y a encore 20 collègues qui
vont poser des questions et que vous
aurez l'occasion de de pouvoir revenir
sur voilà c'est sur le le la la partie
mixité pour l'enseignement privé où je
veux revenir sur les trois dispositions
la constitution d'une base de données
publique qui nous permettra de bien
avoir toute la transparence nécessaire
sur les conditions d'accès à ces
établissements privés de l'évolution de
la mixité à la fois sociale et scolaire
dans ces établissement d'avoir aussi
plus de transparence sur le renforcement
de de l'accueil des élèves à besoins
éducatifs particuli mais aussi sur une
mesure très importante de renforcement
de la mixité sociale à travers
l'engagement d'une augmentation d'au
moins 50 % en 5 ans du nombre
d'établissements privés qui proposeront
des contributions familiales modulées en
fonction des revenus je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre
donc on va prendre l'autre série de
question et Madame la Ministre répondra
de façon
exhaustive aux questions auxquelles n'a
pas éventuellement répondu à la première
salve nous commençons par céine calvz
pour une
minute merci madame la présidente madame
les ministre dans les trois axes de
votre feuille de route vous pointez
l'épanouissement républicain comme étant
une de vos priorité cela touche aussi
bien à l'émancipation individuelle qu'à
la cohésion de nos sociétés vous avez
cité les cours d'empathie pouvez-vous
nous rappeler le cadre de
l'expérimentation de ces cours
d'empathie quel calendrier quel type
d'expérimentation ou de ressources fait
aux enseignants dans ce cadre il y a 2
semaines vous introduisiez un collocque
que j'organisais à l'Assemblée nationale
sur le développement de l'altérité à
l'école de l'empathie jusqu'à la mixité
vous avez pour préparer votre
intervention pu consulter le rapport de
l'école du nous qui pointe et qui relève
toutes les expérimentations qui
cultivent ce goût de l'autre que ce soit
des jumelage entre écle d'un même d'une
même ville ou encore des montées
alternées dans des collèges il y a tout
un tas de ressources quels sont les
moyens que vous souhaitez mettre à
disposition pour leur plus grande
diffusion dans notre pays merci Madame
la Ministre madame la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
députée
alors voilà ah non mais alors là oui ben
oui en fait
je MTA je m'étais dit qu'on était ça
faisait longtemps qu'on était pas passé
soit à laabc de Bertrand chamerois soit
dans quotidien et qu'au moins c'était
une occasion et je pense que voilà c'est
c'est fait donc comme ça c'est fait
voyez donc non mais il faut de temps en
temps savoir détendre l'atmosphère comme
cela donc Madame
Jaouen merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre c'est une question que j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion d'entretenir avec
votre prédécesseur monsieur hatal et
c'est une question qui me tient à cœur
la question du handicap dans l'éducation
nationale euh vous ne respectez pas les
quôas d'emploi de personnes en situation
de handicap qui vous sont imposé et
l'éducation nationale paye un total de
31,8 million d'euros de pénalité alors
qu'elle n'en investit que 6,3 dans
l'adaptation de son matériel et de ses
infrastructures pour son personnel
handicapé c'est un gaspillage de moyens
de 25 millions d'euros et une volonté de
ne pas permettre à des personnes
parfaitement capables d'enseigner et
ceci à l'heure où un manque de
professeur est est l'un des problèmes
les plus régulièrement soulevés et qui
concerne donc notre système éducatif
monsieur hatal lorsque je lui avais posé
la question m'av fait part des
principales mesures entreprises pour
répondre à ce problème politique
d'allégement de service adaptation des
postes constitution de réseau de
conseillers et cetera et un plan qu'
pour les années 2023 2027 qui tendrait
donc à simplifier les démarches
administratives pour ces personnels
enseignants je souhaiterais connaître
votre position merci madame la députée
Christophe
Marion merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre en août dernier le président
avait affirmé vouloir réinventer nos
bonnes vieilles écoles normales le
Premier ministre a confirmé cette
ambition dans sa déclaration de
politique générale en annonçant que le
gouvernement présenterait d'ici la fin
du mois mois de mars une réforme de la
formation des enseignants j'y suis
sensible puisque'avec mon collègue
Philippe F nous avions dédié notre
premier rapport sur l'enseignement
scolaire à cette question nous avions
noté les avancées mises en place par
notre majorité teles que la
professionnalisation du concours de
recrutement et de la maquette du Master
MEF néanmoins nous préconisions des
améliorations une meilleure lisibilité
de l'écosystème de la formation ainsi
qu'une réforme du contenu de celle-ci
pour qu'elle apporte savoir
disciplinaire et pédagogique une
formation plus professionnalisante tout
au long du parcours m'apparaîtrait en
effet plus efficace attractive le groupe
de travail transpartisan mené au sein de
notre commission par mes collègues
Cécile riaac et Céline calvz arrivé à
cette même conclusion et proposait
également d'avancer le concours de
recrutement à la fin de la 3è année
d'étude le gouvernement semble
considérer cette option dès lors
pourriez-vous madame la ministre nous
faire un point d'étape sur la réforme en
cours de construction merci monsieur le
député Jean-Claude
rau merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous déclariez vendredi si je
suis un symbole de quelque chose c'est
de la volonté d'avancer or si vous vous
êtes devenu un symbole c'est celui d'un
autre monde loin si loin du quotidien
des professeurs et des élèves de l'école
publique j'ai passé 25 ans enseignant en
Lycée Professionnel où les catégories
socio-pressionnelles des familles
étaient très éloignées de celles du 6e
arrondissement mon travail est celui de
mes collègues n'étaient pas aussi
prestigieux que les fonctions que vous
avez occupé peut-être pas moins utile ou
fatigant beaucoup moins rémunérateur en
tout cas je gagné 26 fois moins par an
que vous à la Fédération Française de
Tennis 72 fois moins que vous chez
Carrefour mais vous rassure je n'ai
jamais fait perdre de paquet d'heur aux
élèves qui m'étaient confiés et nai
croisé que des collègues riches de leur
passion par reconnu ou récompensé à la
hauteur de leur engagement aussi madame
la ministre alors que tout crédit semble
irréédiablement perdu comment
pourrions-nous croire à votre ambition
pour l'éducation nationale et ses
personnels merci monsieur le député
Sylvie
bonnet merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre ces derniers jours je suis
allée à la rencontre des enseignants et
des familles inquiètes des FA ure
annoncé de classes dans la Loire dont je
suis élu notamment à surille Compal et à
Saint-George aueville pourtant le 17
juillet 2018 lors de la première
conférence nationale des territoires le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron avait annoncé je cite les
territoires ruraux ne peuvent plus être
la variable d'ajustement il n'y aura
plus aucune fermeture de classe dans les
zones rurales plus que jamais cette
promesse doit être tenue madame la
ministre allez-vous demander aux daenes
de revoir leurs copies merci merci
madame la députée Philippe Emmanuel
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en octobre 2023 les services du
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'époque Gabriel Atal déclarer
travailler actuellement à un système de
gestion des mobilités de nos enseignants
qui soit plus humain plus individualisé
avec un meilleur accompagnement depuis
plusieurs semaines je suis saisi dans ma
circonscription sur des demande de
mutation en instruction défavorable ou
rejeté malgré le bien fondé de leur
requête en effet les enseignants et
leurs familles m'écrivent concernant les
injustices ressenties avec ce système de
barê rigide qui favorise l'ancienneté et
donc plus souvent les enseignants
seniors au détriment des enseignants
plus jeunes qui sont plus enclins à la
mobilité et à changer de
territoire pour de jeunes professeurs
ces situations fragilisent leur
équilibre familial et leur projet
personnel
conduisant souvent à des démissions
malgré le dévouement quotidien à exercer
leur métier avec passion nous voulons
tous garder nos jeunes professeurs et
sommes conscients des difficultés à
réformer un tel système quelles sont les
avancées que vous pouvez nous
communiquer à ce sujet merci merci
monsieur le député Laurent es
queengx merci madame la Présidente j'ai
bon mon micro oui madame la ministre
lors de déplacement en mars 2023
Elisabeth borne et le ministre de
l'époque papendia annoncer une carte
scolaire pensée de manière pluriannuelle
dès la rentrée 2024 avec une visibilité
à 3 ans cette décision permettait
d'éviter un effet yoyo de fermeture et
des ouvertures de classes ces
fluctuations pèsent sur l'organisation
des communes particulièrement des
communes rural elles inquiètent nos
maires et nos élus et laissent
s'installer une impression de
délaissement de l'État en décalage avec
l'action globale du gouvernement pour
l'école dans l'oraguet pourtant chez moi
13 à 15 fermetures de classe sont à
nouveau attendu à la rentrée 2025 comme
l'année dernière ces fermetures
conduisent souvent à la création de
classes à double triple niveau ou à la
dévitalisation de nos campagnes aussi
pensez-vous qu'une pose dans la
fermeture de classe qui peuv parfois se
justifier serait nécessaire afin de
mettre en place de façon apaisée cette
planification de 3 ans je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député Inaki et chaniz
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre école inclusive alerte sur un
système qui qui craque titre aujourd'hui
le monde oui madame la ministre les
équipes enseignantes craquent les
parents craquent les enfants crap
comment mener une véritable politique
d'inclusion des enfants en situation de
handicap quand ils ne sont pas
comptabilisés dans les effectifs des
classes par vos services au moment de la
carte scolaire et des DHG sont-ils des
variables d'ajustement comment mener une
véritable politique d'inclusion quand
ces élèves rejoignent des classes déjà
surchargé du fait de vos suppressions de
postees qui ne permettent pas aux
enseignants de leur consacrer le temps
nécessaire la réalité en quelques
chiffres école publique saint-crique
d'Oloron une suppression de classe pour
la prochaine rentrée CE2 déjà 26 27
élèves plus 2 en inclusion soit 29
élèves CM2 26 élèves plus 5 en inclusion
soit 31 ils seront 24 en CP 21 en CM1
nous sommes pourtant le fameux
territoire éducatif rural collège
amicoussé de Saint-Palais suppression de
deux classes trois classes à 31 en 4e et
deux classes à 33 en 3e je pourrais vous
citer d'autres exemples tout ça sans
compter les aesh non madame la ministre
les murs de classe ne sont pas
extensibles non madame la ministre le
dévouement et la passion des équipes
éducatives et des parents ne sont pas
extensible et si rester quelques
secondes je vous interrogerai sur votre
vision sur les langues régionales etul s
précéd Ann le député Béatrice
bami merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre il y a quelques mois votre
prédécesseur a fait un choix fort et
attendu celui de fixer les épreuves
écrites de de spécialité du bac au mois
de juin j'ai rencontré récemment un
groupe de professeurs de sciences
économique et sociale de ma
circonscription ils m'ont alerté sur la
lourdeur du programme et l'impossibilité
d'arriver à à son terme pour les
épreuves du mois de juin en effet le
programme de ses comptait se chapitres
évaluables lorsque les épreuves étaient
en mars ce sont 12 que les élèves
devront maîtriser pour juin 2024 avec
seulement un trimestre de plus qu'est-ce
que cela signifie une course contre le
temps des cours en polycopie à la va
vite l'absence de temps pour évaluer et
remédier d'évidence un programme trop
lourd nuit à la qualité des
apprentissages et à l'épanouissement des
élèves cela nuit également à
l'attractivité du métier aux conditions
de travail le registre de santé et de
sécurité au travail en témoigne il était
indispensable que les épreuves de
spécialité lieu en juin il est désormais
essentiel que les lycéens arrivent bien
préparés avec les mêmes chances de
départ et avec les mêmes enseignements
véritablement maîtrisé madame la
ministre quelles sont les réponses que
votre ministère apporte à ces demandes
et revendications je vous remercie merci
madame la députée
bertrort merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre j'avais prévu de vous
interroger sur le Pact et comment aller
vers une plus large appropriation par
ses enseignants vous y avez répondu je
vous en remercie je souhaitais donc vous
interroger sur la question des stage en
entreprise généralisé à tous les élèves
de seconde c'est effectivement une
excellente décision à mes yeux ancien
enseignant que j'ai pu être afin de
facilité et une orientation réussie
cependant il est constaté souvent par
certains élèves que ces stages se
limitent à de l'observation je pense
qu'il est beaucoup plus utile dans une
période de 15 jours de pouvoir mettre la
main à la patte comme on peut dire mais
simplement les entreprises sont
contraintes par un code du travail qui
est très restrictif dans ces
autorisations avez-vous dans vos projets
ce désir de travailler en transversal
afin de faciliter la réussite de ces
stages en entreprise en permettant aux
élèves d'être acteur de ces stages et
non seulement de se limiter à de
l'observation je vous en remercie merci
monsieur le député Frédéric
meunier merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre encore une fois nous
avons tous la sensation que c'est la
calculette qui a été utilisé pour la
fermeture de classe en effet je viens de
corz où il y a un regroupement une un
RPI avec deux communes à savoir Var sur
auerc et saincir la roche madame la
ministre le maire de saint-ir La Roche a
appris ce matin par le journal qu'une de
ses classes allait fermer elle n'a
jamais jamais été consultée par le daen
vous voyez la réalité est bien
différente de ce que vous dites tout est
très idylique dans ce que vous dites
mais en réalité sur le terrain ça ne se
passe pas comme ça alors vous voulez
changer mais vous voulez changer en
réalité en restant avec les mêmes
données avec les mêmes éléments ça ne
marchera pas ça ne pourra pas permettre
à nos classes à nos enseignants à nos
parents d'élèves d'être rassurés venez
sur le terrain on vous expliquera merci
merci Madame la député Jérôme Legavre
madame la ministre je me concentrerai
sur un point les groupes de niveau
partout dans les établissements les
personnels font leur compte ils
constatent des baisses de moyens les
dispositifs existants les dédoublements
de classe les groupes de sciences de
langu sont sacrifié les suppressions de
postees se multiplient et de nouveaux
professeurs sont obligés de partager
leurs services sur plusieurs
établissements en 6e les élèves perdent
encore une heure de cours les personnels
qui connaissent déjà le désastre de la
réforme du lycée de Jean-Michel Blanquer
ne veulent pas des groupes de niveau
quant aux classes de prépa prépa seconde
accueillant des recalés au brevet on
aurait été en droit d'attendre un
enseignement renforcé c'est le contraire
qui aura lieu ces élèves auront droit à
seulement 18h et demi d'enseignement et
ceux optant pour l'apprentissage ne
seront pas asraint à cette prépa seconde
bref il s'agit ici d'un choc contre le
savoir d'une opération de sélection et
de déqualification de la jeunesse madame
la ministe par pitié ficher la paix aux
enseignants et aux élèves abandonner ces
mesures qui suscitent la colère des
personnels rétablissz les milliers de
postes supprimés depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron est au
pouvoir merci monsieur le député
Emmanuel Pellerin merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre le
président de la République a lancé le
Conseil national de la refondation le 8
septembre dernier ce projet apporte un
soutien unique pour aider les
professeurs à créer des projets visant à
améliorer les performances des élèves
jusqu'à présent 12531 projets ont été
déposés la commission académique en a
approuvé 5548 au bénéfice de
1009 élèves pour un montant de 88,7
millions d'euros de financement l'acte 1
du du CNR a initié une transformation
profonde de l'organisation de
l'éducation nationale son acte 2 vise à
encourager l'innovation
pédagogique je salue le projet du CNR
qui vient en appui du choc des savoirs
il doit se consacrer pleinement au
service de la réussite des élèves et à
l'acquisition des connaissances
fondamentales ma question est la
suivante quel premier bilan faites-vous
du Conseil national de la refondation
sur ces 5 derniers mois merci infiniment
merci monsieur le député Alexandre
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous avons les programmes les
plus chargés qu' soit en Scien
économique et social c'est plus de 12
chapitres que les professeurs doivent
traiter dans l'année et j'ai le
programme d'ailleurs i si vous voulez
vérifier la liste des items et des
sujets à étudier dans l'année est
absolument délirant aujourd'hui très
concrètement en pratique pour être dans
le vif du sujet ça fait guerre plus de
semaines et demi quand on compte tous
les aléas de la vie scolaire de semaines
et demi par chapitre et je dis bien dans
le meilleur des cas parce que en
pratique bien des enseignants ne pouront
pas finir le programme nos programmes
sont trop surchargés et les ses qui sont
la deuxième spécialité la plus choisie
après les maths en terminal on est un
exemple flagrant l'absesse l'association
des professeurs de sciences économiques
et sociales vous a interpellé comme vos
prédécesseurs auparavant sur ce sujet
nous vous demandons donc Madame la
Ministre d'engager une évaluation de ces
programmes interroger par exemple vos
inspecteurs généraux qui vous
expliqueront à quel point il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de procéder à un
allègement dès maintenant sans attendre
et surtout écouter ceux qui font l'école
à commencer par les enseignants remci
merci monsieur le député belkir
baladad merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur la prise en charge des
enfants en situation de handicap sur le
temps périscolaire la volonté est
d'accompagner le parcours des enfants
milieu scolaires dans le milieu
ordinaire comme dans le milieu
spécialisé car il importe d'offrir aux
enfants un panel de solutions diversifié
et adaptable tout au long de leur
parcours en vertu du principe
d'inclusion la scolarisation milieu
ordinaire des enfants en situation de
handicap est recherché systématiquement
vous avez indiqué la prise en charge par
l'État de ces temps périscolaires et
c'est une excellente nouvelle un
engagement fort car pour éviter toute
rupture dans l'accompagnement force de
constater jusqu'à une période récente
que de nombreux maires se à cette
difficulté dans l'application de ces
mesures pouvez-vous nous apporter des
précisions et notamment les modalités
d'application de cette prise en charge
merci merci monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine madame la ministre de conférence
de presse le président de la République
a affirmé qu'il avait réussi à répondre
aux problèmes des absences longues des
professeurs durant son premier quinquena
il s'était félicité et je cite de
résultats formidables or dans ma
circonscription and dromois je déplore
un certain nombre d'absences longues non
remplacé parfois depuis la rentrée
vous-même vous avez fustigé un paquet
d'heur pas sérieusement remplacé
accusation infondé dans votre cas mais
bien réel partout en France les chiffres
sont éloquents le taux de couverture des
absences longues à reculé de 3 points
depuis 2017 dans le primaire ce taux est
de 78 % contre plus de 90 % en 2006
signe d'une réelle dégradation alors
madame la ministre reconnaissez-vous
qu'il existe un réel problème concernant
les absences de longue durée
contrairement à ce qu'affirme le
président de la République et quels
moyens proposez-vous pour remédier à
cette dégradation de notre système
scolaire merci madame la députée
Jean-Jacques
Gautier madame la ministre je voudrais
vous réinterroger sur les moyens alloués
dans le cadre de l'ouverture des groupes
de niveau notamment pour les petits
établissements ruraux le compte n'y est
pas d'où la crainte exprimée ici
d'ailleurs d'aller les chercher ailleurs
notamment au niveau de certaines options
letin l'allemand ça a été rappelé ce qui
est ce qui serait scandaleux crainte
aussi pour les
secp puisqu'on observe de nombreuses
fermetur de classe et il y a une
véritable crainte de disparition des des
secpas au nom de l'école inclusive
certes mais ceci est paradoxal parce que
ça va l'inverse de ce qui est prené pour
les groupes de niveau c'est
problématique parce que ça génère des
difficultés pour les enseignants et
également pour les élèves et puis c'est
injuste parce que les ont d'excellents
résultats 80% d'élèves qui poursuivent
au lycée professionnel et 40 % jusqu'à
l'obtention d'un diplôme Bac pro ou cap
quelle est votre position pour ce
maintien du dispositif
Seca merci monsieur le
député de la porte oui merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre je suis je
pense comme la plupart de mes collègues
dans cette situation un peu
d'incertitude qui nous caractérise à
l'heure actuelle on sait pas si vous
nous répondez pour une durée limité ou
si vos réponses engagent le gouvernement
au-delà duurmanimement soitite en
passant vous avez tout à l'heure eu des
propos question au gouvernement qui
était tout aussi linire que la situation
en disant si le nombre d'enfants est
trop réduit par classe
c'est toute l'émulation qui est remise
en cause tous les professeurs vous le
diront bah écoutez je sais pas il faut
peut-être le demander aux parents qui
mettent leurs enfants dans des cours
particuliers ceux qu' ont les moyens
ceux qui peuvent se payer des scolarités
dans le privé aussi et vous leur
demanderez si il faut ou pas mettre les
enfants en situation d'apprentissage
dans des petits groupes voir en
situation individuelle vous avez détruit
le dispositifs plus de M que de classe
mais vous avez aussi refusé de
revaloriser les AED les a sache on le
voit partout bref madame la ministre
entendez-vous la colère qui merci
monsieur le député donc là comme nous
nous sommes des députés qui sont hors
commission je serai intraitable sur les
une minute Patrick
Etzel merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la ministre je
voudrais revenir sur la question des
territoires ruraux en effet les zones
rurales font face à de nombreusesulté
scolaire et c'est pour cela que vos
prédécesseurs ont considéré qu'il
fallait mettre en place des territoires
éducatifs ruraux
euh aujourd'hui les moyens des TER
restent pourtant inférieurs à ceux des
cités éducatives et si j'écoute Gabriel
hatal il disait encore il y a quelques
semaines que les TER étaient les
équivalent des cités éducatives en
milieu rural donc pourquoi n'y a-t-il
pas le même type de moyen pour les TER
autre question le 31 mars dernier madame
borne a indiqué que désormais les
fermetures de classe notamment en milieu
rural se
an àance la question estès pour la rée
àenir C de 2024 est-ce que vous donnerez
des cons à vos services pour que
effectivement il n'y ait pas de
fermeture de classe avant d'avoir
prévenu 3 années à l'avance les él
député Monsieur
diilippo Merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la ministre concernant
les 30 HE d'activités sportive par jour
à l'école on commence à avoir des
premières
remonté 30 minutes pardon 30 minutes de
sport par jour moi je suis un adepte de
la pratique sportive de fond et puis
vous savez les premières remontées nous
montrent que il manque du matériel que
les professeurs sont insuffisamment
formés que les lieux ne sont pas
forcément adaptés que le temps déjà de
les mettre en place et bien en consomme
quasiment la totalité du du temps prévu
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait
réaménager cette pratique prévoir
l'intervention d'association extérieure
avec des entraîneurs qui sont souvent
diplômés spécialistes de cette de cette
pratique là on ne peut pas espérer
simplement via ces 30 minutes donner le
goût du sport à notre jeunesse moi je
crois que ça passe vraiment par le
milieu associatif et par des pratique
encadré quelle conclusion tirez-vous de
votre côté de ces premiers retours
d'expérience merci merci monsieur le
député monsieur
Cordier merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais insister madame la ministre sur
les départements frontaliers c'est le
cas du département des Ardennes et la
pointe de Givet qui est euh encerclé par
nos amis belges et à l'occasion de de
fermeture de de classe beaucoup de de
familles décident d'envoyer leurs
enfants en Belgique mais j'imagine que
c'est vrai aussi dans d'autres pays
frontaliers je voulais vous demander
s'il ne serait pas souhaitable en tout
les cas madame la Présidente c'est le
cas dans le département des ardenes mais
la pointe de Givet il y a aucune
équivalent en
France bon vous la connaissez bien donc
il y a beaucoup de de familles qui
mettent leurs enfants après en Belgique
parce que des des petites classes ferm
et donc je voulais vous demander s'il ne
serait pas souhaitable d'envisager non
pas une politique à part pour les zones
frontalières mais en tous les cas
d'avoir une attention toute particulière
sur les fermetures de classe à proximité
de nos voisins européens je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
député nous en venons normalement à la
fin des questions des députés donc si
jamais je n'avais pas eu connaissance de
quelqu'un c'est le moment parce que
maintenant c'est bon non non on ne
repose pas de question monsieur Chanis
madame la ministre c'est à vous pour la
réponse à ces
questions merci madame la Présidente
alors peut-être un premier point que je
voudrais absolument souligner c'est que
contrairement à ce qui a pu être dit
dans certaines
questions l'amélioration des taux
d'encadrement que j'ai mise en avant sur
le primaire elle ne vaut pas que pour
les zones REP et REP plus j'insiste sur
ce point et je vous redonne les chiffres
elle était euh le nombre d'élèves par
classe était de 24 en
2017 aujourd'hui elle est de 22,5 c'est
un point et demi d'amélioration
hors éducation
prioritaire ça me semble très important
euh de bien le le le marteler et
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres au global
cette amélioration elle vaut tant pour
la maternelle que pour l'élémentaire
bien entendu
alors les cours d'empathie voilà une
belle belle innovation et qui est en
effet on va dire enrichi dans ses
perspectives par les travaux que j'ai pu
écouter dont j'ai pu prendre
connaissance de la Fédération de la
Fondation pardon Jean jorè depuis
janvier
2024 alors qu'on visait une école
expérimentatrice par des appartement on
en a au global à date plus de 1200 qui à
travers le pays se sont engagés dans la
mise en place de l'expérimentation des
pratiques qui doivent nous permettre à
la fois de travailler sur la découverte
de l'altérité mais aussi sur le
développement des compétences
psychosociales de nos enfants donc on
aura une
évaluation de cette
expérimentation on interrogera à la fois
les élèves mais aussi les personnel et
nous regarderons l'impact sur le climat
scolaire puisque ce développement des
relations de confiance à l'échelle de la
classe au sein de la communauté
éducative doit aussi favoriser
l'apaisement la qualité du climat
scolaire et pas seulement lutter contre
prévenir les problématiques de
harcèlement sur le sujet de la mutation
des enseignants on sait aujourd'hui que
26000 enseignants du second degré part
participe à des opérations à des temps
de mobilité le processus d'affectation
de nos enseignants il tient compte
d'abord de leur parcours professionnel
mais aussi bien sûr de leur situation
personnelle et familiale
l'accompagnement au plus près des
besoins c'est évidemment l'objectif la
cible l'approche que nous poursuivons
avec une volonté de développer
l'accompagnement RH de proximité dans
les rectorats et aujourd'hui on a déjà
41 % des enseignants qui ont participé à
des opérations de mobilité qui
obtiennent satisfaction sur leurs vœux
en la matière on doit continuer et c'est
la raison pour laquelle une réflexion
est d'ors et déjà engagée pour favoriser
cette plus grande fluidité dans les
parcours et dans le développement des
mobilités on sait que c'est aussi un
enjeu pour l'attractivité du
métier sur le sujet des personnels
handicapés vous avez raison de souligner
que il y a en la matière des des
difficultés pour atteindre le
pourcentage qui est recherché on a deux
enjeux qui sont un peu différents
d'abord d'arriver à favoriser la
déclaration par les personnels qui sont
concernés de leur handicap trop souvent
ces personnes n'osent pas exprimer ce ce
handicap et ne demandent pas du coup les
aménagements auxquels ils auraient
pourtant droit c'est pas spécifique à
l'éducation nationale mais on a besoin
de progresser en la matière avec une
bonne communication à cette fin puis le
deuxième enjeu c'est d'arriver à attirer
mieux les personnels qui sont en
situation de handicap de faire tomber un
peu les appréhensions les plafonds de
verre et là c'est un enjeu collectif
qu'on connaît à travers la société et
qui justifie notamment des initiatives
dans lesquelles j'ai été personnellement
extrêmement engagé dans le monde du
sport dans le cadre des duod par
exemple sur le sujet des fermetures de
de classe en en R rité je redis mon
engagement à ce que il y ait un travail
de prospective à 3 ans dans sur la carte
scolaire qui puisse être entrepris que
toutes les instances de dialogue de
concertation entre les services des
rectorats des académies et les élus
fonctionne comme elles le doivent et
qu'on ait le développement des formules
que représentent les territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui doivent nous
permettre là encore de fédérer autour
des élèves autour des enfants tous les
acteurs qui peuvent euh participer à
leur éveil on a des résultats qui sont
probants dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire
avec les cités éducatives c'est la
transposition et son adaptation de ce
dispositif en milieu rural nous aurons à
la rentrée prochaine près de
195 de ces territoires éducatifs ruraux
et c'est un un une mobilisation de
moyens importante puisque c'est près de
6 millions d'euros qui sont mobilisés à
à raison de
30000 euros par territoire éducatif
rural je voudrais revenir sur les
apports du CNR c'est en effet une
initiative extrêmement importante le CNR
éducation on a en la matière investi 500
millions d'euros sur 5 ans pour que
chaque école chaque établissement puisse
vraiment construire son projet
pédagogique innover et
proposer à l'échelon de proximité des
évolution dans les approches
pédagogiques la dynamique est super bien
engagée on a aujourd'hui plus de 12000
projets qui ont été déposés près de 6000
d'entre eux qui ont été validés par la
commission académique au bénéfice de
près de 2 millions d'élèves déjà pour
presque 90 millions d'euros engagés on a
aujourd'ui i un appel à projet national
qui a été lancé auprès des académies et
nous aurons prochainement un temps de
communication sur les projets les plus
innovants pour continuer à engager cette
démarche qui doit aussi nous permettre
de répondre à certaines des orientations
que nous voulons dans le cadre du choc
des savoirs et je pense notamment au
renforcement des méthodes en matière de
mathématique et tout particulièrement à
la démarche impulsé à Singapour qui a
fait ses preuves là-bas et que nous
voulons essayer d'expérimenter le plus
le plus possible voilà la cible sur ce
registre c'est vraiment un projet CNR
dans chaque école ou établissement sans
se mettre des contraintes temporelles
excessives mais en s'engageant avec
confiance dans ses dispositif en lien
avec
laadgesco et le préfet Abrar qui pilote
cette démarche à laquelle je suis
particulièrement
attentive sur le sujet euh des sec pages
je je le redis euh pas
de groupe de niveau dans les classes de
secpa ces classes aujourd'hui elles
offrent une réponse pédagogique qui est
adaptée aux besoins des élèves de la 6e
à la 3e et on ne veut pas modifier cette
organisation qui permet déjà de
s'inscrire dans la logique de progrès
pour tous les élèves concernés donc donc
le fonctionnement et les enseignements
en sea ne sont pas impactés par cette
nouvelle organisation qui se mettra en
place à la rentrée prochaine et ce qu'on
veut c'est que l'expertise des
professeurs qui exercent en secpa et qui
est aujourd'hui précieuse dans le
casadre des travaux d'équipe elle se
prolonge pour qu'on conduise ce
changement profond dans les pratiques
pédagogiques dans les modalités aussi de
leur évaluation et on a besoin que les
professeurs de français de math puissent
profiter de l'expérience solide reconnu
de leurs collègues surtout dans les
premiers temps de la mise en place de
cette innovation sur le sujet des
programmes de ses vous avez évoqué le le
report des épreuves en juin et c'est
donc aussi en fin d'année scolaire qu'on
aura ces épreuves de de spécialité comme
pour les autres
disciplines qui vont toutes se dérouler
sur cette fin d'année l'épreuve de ses
elle évaluera l'intégralité des des
connaissances et des compétences qui
doivent être maîtrisées par nos nos
élèves c'est donc un programme qui est
ambitieux qui est engageant qui est
impliquant et on aura une évaluation des
élèves sur la totalité du programme je
sais aujourd'hui que c'est difficile
d'absorber l'intégralité du programme
c'est pourquoi une réflexion sera
engagée sur les contours de ce programme
pour cette
discipline sur la prise en charge des
AESA
sur le temps de la pause
méridienne on sait que depuis une
décision du du Conseil d'État de
2021 c'est la collectivité qui est
censée prendre en charge les enfants en
situation de de handicap qui en ont
besoin qui doivent payer les aesh mais
aujourd'hui on estime à 8 % le nombre
d'élèves qui ont besoin d'une aide
humaine sur la pause méridienne et le
but que nous poursuivons c'est vraiment
d'assurer la continuité de la prise en
charge que l'État puisse puisse aller au
bout de ses responsabilités avec un
cadre stabilisé le gouvernement a donc
annoncé sa volonté de prendre en charge
ce temps-là et nous aurons pour cela un
temps important pour arrêter les
arbitrages et les effectifs
supplémentaires qui seront
éventuellement rendus nécessaires
lorsque l'augmentation du du temps de
travail ne permettra pas d'absorber la
charge avec les revalorisations
salariales
respondante sur le sujet des
remplacements oui nous avons encore du
chemin à mener sur les remplacements de
longue durée j'ai évoqué tout le
dispositif mis en place les arbitrages à
venir sur les remplacements de courte
durée mais nous avons aussi besoin de
continuer à améliorer notre efficacité
sur la longue durée même si pour ces
dispositifs de remplacement de longue
durée c'est en ce sens que le Président
de la République a pu exprimer mais sa
satisfaction c'est que nous avons d'ors
et déjà un système de professeurs
remplaçant dans les écoles avec des
brigades dédiées mais nous avons aussi
des titulaires de zon de remplacement
dans le second degré dans nos collèges
et nos lycées qui nous permettent de
mobiliser des moyens supplémentaires
pour faire face à cette problématique
qui est en effet très importante pour
les familles sur le sujet des
passerelles entre le temps des au sport
sur le le la maquette scolaire et le
rôle joué par les associations c'est
tout le sens notamment au-delà du
déploiement des 30 minutes au primairire
de l'expérimentation que nous menons à
travers le dispositif 2 heures
supplémentaires pour les collégiens qui
vise précisément monsieur le député à
créer ses passerelles vers le mouvement
sportif vers le mouvement associatif et
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un chemin
d'expérimentation où nous sommes passés
de plus de 200 collèges à 700 et a une
nouvelle marche pour laquelle nous
mobilisons 14 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui doit nous permettre
de déployer ce dispositif dans 2000
collèges
volontaires
sur le
sujet
[Musique]
de la prise en compte des besoins
spécifiques de de l'école publique moi
je je voudrais redire en la matière
qu'évidemment le réflexe qui a été le
mien a été
à la rencontre de ces enseignants dans
plusieurs visites de terrain d'évoquer
avec eux non seulement la problématique
du renforcement de l'autorité de nos
professeurs sur la vie de classe sur les
notations sur les décisions de
redoublement sur la maîtrise aussi de
leur enseignement mais aussi le
déploiement plein et entier du choc des
savoirs dans ces différentes dimensions
pour remettre toute l'exigence et en
marche l'ascenseur scolaire mais aussi
le déploiement des dispositifs de suivi
renforcé pour nos élèves j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure les parcours en 6e 5e le
concours apporté par les professeurs des
écoles avec le PACT mais c'est aussi le
sens de la montée en puissance du
dispositif devoirfit et des stages de
réussite avec l'accent que j'ai en effet
souhait mettre pour les élèves de 3e sur
les mathématiques dans une logique là
aussi de mixité pour avoir de
l'excellence d'un côté mais aussi un
appui spécifique pour nos jeunes filles
en la matière
peut-être le dernier point que je veux
mentionner c'est l'attention qui sera la
mienne sur toutes les composantes du
bien-être de nos enseignants bien sûr
l'attractivité des concours avec la
révision que j'ai déjà évoqué des
parcours de formation initiale sur
lesquels des arbitrages seront rendus
dans les prochaines semaines mais aussi
une plus grande attention portée au
résultats des enquêtes au dérouler des
carrières à la prise en compte notamment
de ce que nous pouvons mettre en œuvre
sur les milieux de carrière je ferai des
propositions en ce sens de la même façon
que je veux que nous soyons et c'est
notamment aussi le sens de la mise en
place des groupes de niveau être
attentive aux difficultés que nos
enseignants peuvent exprimer aujourd'hui
dans l'écartellement qui est le leur
dans la gestion difficile délicate de
l'hétérogénéité des classes où on voit
et ils nous le disent lorsque nous les
avons interrogés dans le cadre des
travaux menés sur l'exigence dans les
savoirs il sont aujourd'hui confrontés à
la difficulté qui est exprimée et
partagée à la fois de ne pas parvenir à
suffisamment faire remonter le niveau
des élèves en difficultés et de remédier
à l'ennui que peuvent ressentir un
certain nombre d'élèves qui sont eux sur
des rythmes d'apprentissage un petit peu
plus soutenu aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
pour les aider à mieux gérer cette
hétérogénéité et avec eux que nous
voulons mettre en place ces groupes de
niveau ces groupes de progrès ces
groupes de besoins et que nous les
réagencerons progressivement conseil de
classe après conseil des classes en
écoutant le ressenti des équipes
pédagogiques sur le déploiement du
dispositif je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre je crois
qu'il y avait encore une question
c'était sur les stages en entreprise
auquel vous vous
aviez été
interroger alors sur le sur
les sur sur les élèves en situation de
handicap il y a été
répondu sur on a pour les les effectifs
des enfants en situation de handicap
plus 40 % d'enfants handicapés qui sont
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire depuis
2017 nous avons en même temps vous
l'avez en tête augmenté de moitié nos
aesh avec les 7000 recrutements que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure et une
progression de 40 % des crédits de
rémunération
associé on a fait un effort qui est
inégalé en la matière et dans le même
temps nous avons engagé l'ouverture de
300 à 400 classes ULIS par année de la
même manière que nous confirmons tout le
dispositif des sec pas de manière à
avoir une réponse qui soit à la hauteur
des enjeux pour tous ces enfants tous
ces élèves à besoins éducatifs
particulierers merci madame la ministre
pour ses réponses donc nous vous
recevrons à nouveau mais pour une une
audition cette fois-ci consacrée au
sport et je rappelle mes collègues que
nous nous retrouverons demain matin pour
poursuivre nos travaux sur l'école par
une table ronde consacrée au rapport
entre celle-ci et l'intelligence
artificielle et c'est dans ce n'est pas
dans notre salle stage en entreprise
déjà 200000 offres qui sont postées est
disponible et je mobiliserai l'ensemble
des entreprises mais aussi nos
associations nos services publics nos
établissements publics pour qu'il y ait
un très bon éventail de stages qui
puisse être proposé aux élèves
pardonnez-moi merci madame la ministre
pour ce complément de de réponse et donc
je rappelle au au commissaire de des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
que demain nous n'avons pas notre salle
mais nous nous retrouvons dans la salle
des affaires économiques voilà donc je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée